pal on voulait c'est arrivé
tranquillement mettez une bûche dans la
cheminée on va s'occuper de vous pendant
deux heures numéro un peu spéciale entre
entre dans la sphère des fêtes donc on
et l'estomac rompu un petit peu trop
d'alcool d'ensemble on va quand même
essayer de vous parler big board et
baskets vous l'avez constaté comme à
chaque fois je suis très très très bien
accompagné on à halen et hugues à calais
twitch heures sauvage salut les gars
salut à tous on a remarqué qu' on pense
en ce moment parce que admira schofield
vous à la mairie mme très bas les gones
sur un mirage koffi dont on parle
et enfin le boss himself en direct d'une
contrée lointaine saluer l'ex
bonjour tout le monde
donc on va dans cette émission on va
analyser on commencera par analyser le
tiers 1 puis 2 de cette cuvée 2022
prospère finira par nous chauffe ou du
tiers 3 et bim bien évidemment on va
compter sur vous vous en avez l'habitude
désormais poser vos questions sur le
tchat on va essayer d'y répondre afin
d'être le plus complet possible
on va entrer dans le vif du sujet comme
de bons élèves en définition les termes
je faisais là chez big board et hier
qu'est ce que ces messieurs et qu'elles
sont quelquefois vous avez aussi des
différences dans la façon d'utiliser
donc je vous écoute
allen
chef hockey bas en gros plus que pour
faire un classement 2e en 30 ou à 63
cents
le système de tiers permet en fait de
faire des par étage d un des lots de
joueurs mais les gens qui sont plus ou
moins au même niveau avec un potentiel
plus ou moins similaires et c'était
souvent plus intéressantes être faire un
classement bay 2-1 et 1,30 et 1,60 et
big board chacun peut avoir sa
définition
et c'est le classement ça peut être que
c'est un classement selon nous des
joueurs qui ont peut-être le plus haut
potentiel ou qui sont les meilleurs de
cette cuvée en moment on parle donc
c'est un truc qui évolue au fil de
l'année c'est un truc qui évolue même au
fil des années si on fait des big board
deux ans ou trois en avance et donc
c'est une manière de classer les
prospects du north on
parle aussi j'ai utilisé les moussières
les mood tiers qu'est ce qu'ils
représentent qu'est ce que pour
quelqu'un qui tombe dessus qu'ils voient
tiers un tiers deux qu'ils poussent à
vous dire chers 3/3 4 cr1 c'est le meur
souvent ces voies pour bien la patte en
fait ça dépend parce que ça tire ça peut
être même mouvant et bien de l'année
dernière par exemple on avait un jour le
consensus disait qu'il y avait un seul
joueur dans terrain ça pouvait être faut
d'ailleurs des gens pourraient peut-être
penser commerce c'était quelques nigam
mais cette année par exemple
moi j'aurais personnes dans le tiers de
quelques nigam c'est donc en gros des
joueurs de mentir 1,2 cette année il
serait pas dans ses rangs de l'année
dernière donc encore une fois ces choses
qui évoluent et le laitière en gros moi
je fonctionne un peu en dedans l'inversé
d'un d'un entonnoir c'est à dire toutes
plus on descend non en fait c'est
peut-être un entonnoir où c'est un
entonnoir inversé je sais pas achat si
tôt chesnot qu'une pyramide dimanche la
glace
merci je suis pas très bon architecture
plus on décelait rente est meilleur en
déco
mais voilà donc en gros plus on défend
il ya de joueurs capables d'avoir ce
même en personne le même niveau et hier
un soir en passer le mur jaune d'or
cette année peut-être y en a plusieurs
qui ont ces potentiels là non puis en
décembre - le potentiel et où je pense
et pour ceux qui nous écoutent qui
aurait envie de se mettre cet exercice
période qu'est ce qu'on pourrait leur
donner comme conseil
pour faire un big board
regardez damon c'est ça c'est bien déjà
ça
et
après peut-être regarder les six qui
préfère moi j'aime c'est que j'ai des
styles particuliers et des joueurs qui
ont une panoplie de styles ce qui va
m'intéresser à très très haut niveau je
vais les mettre ensemble et je vais
descendre comme ça en fait des choses
les plus rares les plus générationnel
comme on aime bien dire aux choses les
plus communes les plus classiques et je
vais descendre comme ça au fur et à
mesure en mettant en relation les
différents paramètres
champions à l'âge aussi je dirais je
pense que l'âge c'est quelque chose
d'important s'était fait quelque chose
de très bien à 18 ans c'est plus
important pour moi que si tu le fais
bien 22 ans
il se prépare pour moi là déjà je le
vois
alors messieurs pour rien cacher à ceux
qui sont là vous m'avez envoyé au big
board et ce qui est assez amusant c'est
que déjà en premier il ya quasiment pas
d'accord entre vous
donc je vous laisse commencé la bagarre
commence d'entrée
est-ce qu'on peut peut-être précision un
truc vite fait excuser moi
je crois que pour la plupart d'entre
nous quand on a fait nos big bang on n'a
pas trop on ne s'est pas renseigné entre
et entre nous on n'a pas regardé les
bornes classiques démoc vous pouvez
refaire l'histoire est classique et du
coup ça fait le truc peut-être on se met
pas dans la fin on ce n'est pas une
pression dans la tête en disant tout le
monde mais ce jour à l'an consensus et
du coup on est obligé de se mettre là ce
qui est une pression qu'on a très
souvent je trouve naturellement quand tu
vois dimmock différents joueurs dans le
top 5 certains coûts d'étude sont un peu
obligé de le mettre d'octobre 5 je crois
que cette année on n'a pas ça ce qui
peut peut-être expliquer qu'on soit
explosif non sachant probablement les
mots qu aujourd'hui le 27 décembre le
chef quand même pas forcément un grand
grand chose encore nous l'un des liens
de l'interligue board pardon avec les
chinois
il ya aussi un truc à préciser c'est que
peut-être en guise d'introduction par
les niveaux général de notre tir 1 parce
que comme alan visait ça dépend des
années et
je pense que par exemple cette année ils
mettent moins fort les gens aiment bien
avoir une idée on a souvent la question
dans les commentaires
et donc j'ai pas de drame de comparaison
mais je peux juste dire par exemple que
je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup moins de
joueurs dominants c'est à dire que très
rapidement je suis tombé sur des joueurs
avec des gros gros défauts des grosses
questions après les positions 7 5 6 2 7
draw énormément de questions très vite
et je suis pas sûr non plus que le top
tiers soit fois si fou que ça même si on
a eu des bons débuts de saison et donc
moi à titre personnel je pense que ça
n'est qu'une grave plutôt dans la
moyenne basse
c'est un peu ressenti que j'ai aussi
quand je regarde les bons léger bien je
suis repas pas regardé 60 joueurs la
bande à
devenir ce soir venu en trottant perds
mes mots c'est l'émotion mais je trouve
globalement qui a une ou deux exceptions
près il ya des joueurs qui sont encore
très perfectible et je me demande si à
l'image de ce qui se passe un peu sur
les sur les catégories plus jeunes en
europe on est en train de tomber sur les
premières conséquences du duc au vide
sur le surnombre d'entraînement à
certains moments houleux le manque de le
manque de 55 ont pu voir que certains
mecs donc de travailler compagnie par la
force des choses véritablement et on
voit un petit peu par moment nous sur
les sur les compétitions qu'on joue à un
niveau pro il ya des petites choses
acquis qui nous qui nous font réfléchir
un peu là du côté des coaches ont
peut-être aussi qu'on est sur sa
dimension là j'extrapole totalement jeu
je sais pas mais voilà c'était une idée
aussi
messieurs qui avez vous pris pour vous
quel est le mélange tout et dispos bible
à l'heure actuelle de ce que vous avez
vu
et on va connaître un coup je veux dire
dans le deutscher ouais ils ont pu quel
est ton top voir à l'heure actuelle am
le public je préfère me tapper moi j'me
paulo bunker où tout est ce que tu aimes
des papes un petit peu où on fait juste
un poil car un tour de table auquel ron
kirk de duke
au moins ces trois joueurs dans mon
premier tiers et si je dois en prenant
aujourd'hui c'est un grain cette année
romain
moi j'aurais tendance j'aurais tendance
après je n'ai pas vu assez joué mais sur
les sur les six sur les scènes j'ai
vraiment creuser là qui correspondent
plus ou moins au consensus que vous avez
sur votre sur roddick bordent les uns
les autres j'aurais potentialités pure
est sûre le sur le volume basket je
partirai tordjman
et alex moi je les ai pas mis dans
l'ordre ce chien envoyé d'accord ok vous
voyez le terrain de bari 1 exactement
comme alan et je suis en train de poser
la question de savoir si aux longues
rênes et par un tiers au dessus de tout
donc je prendrais du hockey donc on va
commencer par paraît de deutsch est une
graine qui est dans un coup qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire du contexte de gonzague
à cette année parce qu'ils ont déjà
perdu plusieurs matchs et ce qu'on est
un peu inquiet ou pas
pour la raison collective tu veux dire
vous pour comment il est mis en valeur
et 2 les deux bras y perdre contre duke
bras c'était un vrai gros gros match et
sont tombés ils ont dû faire front à la
barre des 50 buts sont tombés contre une
équipe qui mettait tout dedans donc
qu'il était encore m voilà après c'est
une moins bonne équipe que l'an dernier
je pense qu'ils sont ils sont solides un
mois j'ai une bonne équipe mais sont
moins bons que l'an dernier après voilà
je trouve que kate est très très bien
moi dans ce dans ce dans cette équipe il
est bien servi par des 2des les meneurs
et des mecs qui ont la balle qui sont
qui ont ils sont expérimentés qui ont
des carrières en europe je pense comme
neymar de bolton l'espé singh c'est pas
le plus incroyable même temps vu que tu
chériras trois points c'est pas lui le
nom shooter du
d2 l'équipe de l'été dijoux mais non je
pense que puis là ils vont rentrer dans
les matches wcc je pense que ça va
est-ce que la lutte et envoyer les corps
un peu improbable jusque là ils ont joué
alors bon les amateurs de hennetier
profonde des éliminatoires campus à
pression ils ont joué contre dixie state
alcorn state belles heures my baby et
miou parton state bon il ya quand même
des choses voilà
je me suis je suis fan une partie du
match contre dorfer d'arizona c'était
c'était compliqué est ce que c'est parce
que c'est pas une terreur année où ils
ont un calendrier d'autres choix il ya
des matches c'est pourri un contre des
lots med sur des mines mais désormais
pouvoir jouer juke et alabama c'est
assez rare qu'on puisse observer gonzaga
contre des grosses équipes aussitôt et
donc c'est très intéressant et même pour
nous pas pour nous et pour vous il est
exaucé alors laissez plus intéressant
c'est jouer le condo des équipes qui
vont du deux contre le stade poitevin où
la réserve du pb86 en nationale 2 quad à
flamme des six mois j'ai vu des trucs
tout à l'heure sur synergie j'ai fait
défiler des matchs les possessions et
compagnie de position oui il vaut mieux
vaut mieux des déchets du duke ou
quelque chose sans manquer de respect
aux sorties d'école un maire pendant sur
vos positions et les trucs tellement
curieux émotions ici c'est en regardant
tout à l'heure en regardant dieu ou tout
à l'heure j'ai l'impression de voir bank
iront jouer compter qu'on compte des
enfants ça laisse penser
c'est curieux qu'on est intéressant
c'est que on dit oui cette année c'est
un calendrier plus difficile que
d'habitude parce qu'ils ont voulu se
mettre des opposants très fort
mais si tu regardes le
skate doom
la force
force d'opposition moyenne qu'ils ont
eue
ils sont loin son très bon parce qu'ils
ont joué contre des équipes tellement
pour l'anc
[Musique]
texas
texas des classes alabama dieu qsi et
les haies et texas tech que j'étais sur
cinq fac on va dire plutôt plutôt solide
et voilà c'est ça le reste après il
reste encore manquer de respect pour une
fois mes aînés yume imac ou tard tom
staggs
mêlée alors alors que sur le papier on
parlera paris ce n'est pas prêt mais sur
le papier de larry smith ça ne me
paraissait pas avoir jouer contre des
gros stack mais en fait c'est les packs
tout moyen plus élevé et d'une moyenne
nos positions c'est aussi important pour
les gens qui nous écoutent le regarder
ça surtout quand l'échantillon est petit
en début de saison là on parle joueurs
ont joué 15 matchs en juillet c'est
important de regarder la force
d'opposition qu'ils appellent les uns
par rapport aux autres étant donné les
performances dans les gros matches est
selon moi et des bons dans les landes
ces essais il était mon agrès mais
également ses hôtes chinois de façon de
voir les choses mais des deux équipes
contre lesquelles il a joué j'ai vu où
tous les mecs sont maîtres 95e beaucoup
de suite juste comme ça quand on quand
on fait 2 10 de 15 comme c'est le cas
dès la 2 15 quand on fait 2 15 comme lui
c'est pas forcément de source armes de
jouer contre des gens plus petits ou
plus publique est mise à part le match
contre alabama où il se troue
où il est urgent qu'il y ait ihya
quand il se trouve en parlant juge
gentil il a dix points quand même 10
points 2 rebonds pardon thème annuel
évalué ligne de stats mais sur un
globalement quel que soit l'opposition
ça tient la route il a par contre été
que ça c'était que ça tient la route
c'est que ça ce serait fini à deux
points mais red sox assez fine à deux
c'est ça on est le sémillon mais 37 élus
ne sortait pas ce que j'allais dire mais
l'an dernier par tüv en comparaison pour
gonzague il devait il avait des matches
prévus notamment contre bellor et
l'immaturité annulé pour la pandémie et
le coach du coup de gonzaga disait que
ça leur avait péché de jouer contre des
vrais bonne équipe pour cette
appellation le tournoi est d'arriver au
trône en tête en ayant survolé
totalement la groupe d'édition toute
l'année et qui sont fait prendre comme
ça aussi
donc du coup à part pour revenir après
pensa mais en quoi ce joueur
qu'est ce qui va pouvoir puisque on
suppose qu'il va devenir qui va apporter
qui mérite cette place de numéro 1 tout
de suite
en gros c'est gros point fort et
éventuellement ses points faibles pour
faire un petit trou pour ceux qui l'ont
pas vu dans le chat
lui pour le coup je pense que tu dérapes
de la potentialité parce qu'il est quand
même loin d'être une bière et les
physiquement
ça va prendre peut-être j'ai pas trois
quatre ans globalement mais
[Musique]
si ça si ça se passe bien il ya quand
même un sacré morceau parce que c'est un
joueur qui est malgré sa taille comme
déjà pousse un petit peu le ballon
capable de tirer de loin capable de
faire des choses quand même
techniquement assez intéressante c'est
lui c'est la potentialité chercher
l'équipe qu'il de racheter qui espère le
mettre sur le terrain à 25 ou 30 minutes
la saison prochaine
un peu difficile parce que je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord avec ça je pense
qu'on a vu avec
avec mobley que ce n'est pas si grave
un joueur très bon
défensivement offensivement c'est
d'accord avec roman ça prendra beaucoup
de temps
mais défensivement je sais pas s'il est
tellement long est tellement mobile est
en fait il a pas il n'a pas vraiment
besoin et en plus il est il accepterait
très bien le contact je sais comment
beaucoup d'importance à ça et je trouve
qu'il accepte très très bien contacter
d'ailleurs et produits provoquent des
fautes il en ferait pas beaucoup il ne
fait pas beaucoup par rapport au nombre
de contres qui met notamment tout ça
c'est des éléments de faits importants
et je pense qu'il peut être all nba 10
ans tiphaine ce sit-in dans les têtes
parce qu'ils sont si petits mais tu vois
mobley cette année il a certainement
fait relaxer coin lui seul est dans les
2-3 re année de son contrat rookie à
c'est assez fascinant je pense qu'il a
les mêmes idées les mêmes armes mais il
ya un peu plus grand il est peut-être un
tout petit peu moins mobiles mais les
sinon c'est un peu le même genre de
lionel statistiquement il ya deux fois 2
par match pour un joueur de ce gabarit
en 23 minutes c'est quand même pas grand
chose mais +2 contre il fait deux fautes
à comme tu dis l'a35 3,5 sur les contres
de 20 sur les fautes et il a une limite
physique et sur bas du corps mais qui
est logique parce qu'à pas voir dans une
cuisse ans aujourd'hui par qtel mobilité
et que ouais moi je trouve qu'à moyen
terme ça peut être ça peut être très
intéressant
il ya une stat assez rigolote qui ce
sans doute se traduira pas au niveau nbc
qu'il a pour l'instant aux tirs à deux
points dans l'est près du cercle il est
à 42 sur 45 ce qui est plutôt très très
très correct mais est ce qu'on peut dire
que c'est un il a aussi parce que c'est
un peu le défaut auquel fois qu'on a sur
les joueurs intérieurs
on a aussi un jour qu ils capables de
jouer près du sien imaginez vous être
capable de vous aussi près du cercle au
jour d'aujourd'hui moi de ce que j'en ai
vu
je me trompe peut-être j'ai fait une
grosse impression mais c'est un joueur
qui est ce un jour de mouvement c'est un
joueur qui a beaucoup de mal à jouer
arrêté dire quoi qu'il va rentrer dans
des dons du travail de lutte de position
il part déjà avec un déficit de toute
façon face à des joueurs plus petits aux
plus puissants donc le post up je pense
pas par contre partie en boulet dont le
mouvement qu'il est capable d'enchaîner
sur des attrapés sur du fesf avant
d'enchaîner d'attraper tout de suite est
déjà quelque chose moi je pense qu'il
peut jouer près du cercle sans aucun
problème une vraie qualité de passe il
peut ressortir la balle létale ils sont
bons il est capable de se resituer il ya
énormément de choses que je trouve
intéressant de chez lui dans ce qu'on va
chercher de la panoplie du jour à
l'intérieur de manière globale
il est entre le 4 et le 5 c'est vraiment
un intérieur moderne aujourd'hui sur
cette partie là voilà après
effectivement il n'est pas assez solide
pour le poster mais il est capable
d'avoir des hooks hurler demain jeudi
capables d'être institué c'est très
mobiles pas forcément très rapide sur
tout mais bon ils montrent bien c'est
bon je ne sais pas et les joueurs
intérieurs quand on leur apprend à jouer
ça c'est des choses avec lesquelles on
se bat parfois que des joueurs
expérimentés c'est la demande et laval
ça il le fait montrer ses mains il le
fait donc déjà à l'intérieur qui veut le
ballon quand il est dans le mouvement
c'est déjà quelque chose
je les uns si tu veux pierre parce qu'en
fait pour moi c'est le seul qui a un
potentiel plus plus plus plus dans un
domaine de cette offre est pour moi
c'est la protection de cirque chais de
château - ce qui fait quand il est sur
le terrain il change je trouve un jeu
page par écrit des choses qui changent
la manière dont les attaques fonction
fonctionne ça drive plus continuer là ça
s'arrête ça a peur il a vraiment cette
qualité là alors franche et que j'ai
beaucoup de gens sont un peu moins au
coeur avec lui parce que dans la tête
des gens victor hedman yamal a donc
battu en finale geo pour moi ce en
disait plus sur victor que sur les
rochers alléger ou alan tu t'enflammes
un peu ses 34 ans peut-être finale du 19
pendant dix neuf et pour moi si on
disait peu sur victor qui en prospects
incroyable que sur jet qui lui
d'ailleurs a été dans le mur prennent à
la compet a dominé sur les matches de la
compétition
et donc en fait ouais là il à ceux il a
ce potentiel défensif plus puisque plus
comme alex l'a dit il n'a pas peur
nasser d'inquiétude des fois mais je
trouve un à un à faire en fait il va au
charbon et à 14% de contre sur l'année
c'est un freshman c'est très intéressant
sur la finition en panne et comme tu
l'as dit ouais il a pas mal de paniers
faciles à néant il affrontait celle ci
le jeu collectif très léché de gonzague
qui lui permirent décidemment pas mal ou
pas c'est dans cette équipe ce qui passe
est un peu du coup la transition et on
est tout trouvé toi tu étais le seul
dans dream et dissonant avec en mettant
banque héros pour qu'est ce qui te plaît
chez bang héros une puisse plus dois
dire que je valorise toujours alors là
avec celle que j'aime bien les ailiers
je valorise toujours un joueur qui peut
créer balle en main qui pourra créer
vraiment dans un contexte tout pourri
très rapidement je pense qu'une équipe
qui au fond en tant que de l'autre il va
chercher de la création sur un jour
supérieures et bankir là-dessus il est
prêt
monte directement le ballon il a des
très bons fondamentaux des très bon
départ c'est un jour qui puissant qui
peut marquer toutes les distances et qui
peut être important de balle nba très
très rapidement à l'image de ce qu'a pu
faire un indigène tatsumi ya quelques
années qui lui sont faits de juke aussi
et donc je valorise toujours ça entre
deux joueurs celui qui pourra le mieux
porté le ballon à terme est aussi assez
rapidement pour exploiter son potentiel
et c'est pour ça que je n'avais plus
haut c'est un jeu voilà c'est un joueur
qui est vraiment des fondamentaux
extrêmement solide qui a de la
potentialité qui a de la puissance et
qui a dû toucher
est-ce que la limite de tout
raisonnement c'est que au cas
l'intérieur à être numéro 1 je pense
je pense faudra faudra voir l'année
prochaine ce que peut présenter du temps
en tout cas pas à l'intérieur ou aux
récréateurs qui dribble vraiment qu'ils
puissent vraiment créé balle en main ce
que tu fais tu arrives à faire sur
surduts postaux et pouvoir partir une
main demain comme ça mais depuis anthony
davis y a pas un joueur de ce poste là
qui m'a qui m'a fait c'est dur pour
passer en premier quoi donc peut être
aussi que le ton raisonnement du
toujours favorisé d'un ailier par
rapport à l'intérieur
murray nadal il a quand même pas encore
une fois ont patienté sur les stats mais
le mec en 23 minutes certes condé
adversaire en partie en partie à il faut
pondérer mais bon c'est ce que lui un
coach avec lequel j'ai bossé quelques
années 3,4 compte par match ah oui
certainement régionales mais même en
régionale 2 faut les faire
vous faut y aller quand même il a un
côté on veut rentrer dans le jeu en 23
minutes encore une fois 2 rebonds 2
projeter sur 28 on est à 3 et quelque 8
rebonds 5 projeter sur 28 ont répondu on
est à plus de 10 les contres projeter
sur 28 minutes on se rapproche peut-être
2,4 quelque chose on peut dire que le
mec il est sensationnel et c'est le jour
le plus long qu'on ait vues depuis des
années mais en tout cas sur la
potentialité et sur la qualité des
fondamentaux et la transposition qui
peut voir dans un jeu elin et moi il
plaît plus que certains bancaire où j'ai
regardé oui bonne chair rouge pas trop
comme on dit j'ai un directeur sportif
italien mais je parle pas italien il ya
des choses que j'aime bien chez lui mais
moi je trouve un peu lourd dans ce qu'il
fait
il ya des choses il est des facteurs
limitants alors que notamment dans dans
le fait de deux des accès aux contacts
sur ces jo dan je vois pas cher une
gamme sont des profils différents unis
vite ablement prix historiquement tu as
raison il mais je choisis à choisir je
repartirai sur la jante rebuter et
qu'est ce que tu veux dire par lourd
physiquement physiquement avis les
banquiers oui là il a un profil qui a
une vieille règle
mais mais je vois pas je vois pas un
joueur encore une fois c'est peut-être
une une comment dire une impression qui
est faussé par la vidéo par le fait que
bon les angles sont pas toujours bon
mais
c'est un joueur qui est athlétique mais
c'est pas un jour que je trouve dans
l'explosivité
comment expliquer ça
le problème est que je trouve m'explose
cuisse 9000 est pliée plus il est plus
puissant qu'explosive pour moi car il
est très puissant c'est un train
clairement mais il est plus puissant
qu'explosive ce qui fait aussi qu'il ya
beaucoup de jeunes stop dans son jeu
mais qui va pas forcément monter sur un
pied il ya énormément quand on regarde
jouer il ya beaucoup de jeunes stop
beaucoup de feintes il a besoin en ligne
droite pour driver pour annoncer à
chinon ces jams top 10 fait quelque
chose derrière il a bien passé de ce ou
sur des pylônes d'heure se retourne et
des choses comme ça mais le fait qu'il
soit puissant fait aussi quelque part et
des axes très peu donc s'élever qui va
se retourner il va se retourner que le
ballon dans max du corps c'est des
petites choses moi qui me
qui me plaisent moins après il m'a
gauche qu'il ya un argument la main
gauche est convenable ya des trucs
intéressants il aime aussi des mots s'y
attaquer sur 120 gauche mais je trouve
pas forcément assez
assez assez verticale puis y est plus
puissant qu'exploser secours c'est
intéressant parce qu'elle est beaucoup
de comparaisons et moi-même regardant
j'ai
vu du jeune jeune carmelo anthony en lui
mais c'est vrai qu'à passe peut-être pas
ce premier pas joyeux gauche et la tête
peut-être pas ce premier pas
c'est juste un dream stop c'est l'armé
lourde carmelo anthony pour moi ça je
suis sûr de m'engueuler personnes
notamment avec une personne en
particulier mais carmelo anthony je suis
en termes de fluidité
cesser ces travaux
flutey la capacité sur un tir c'est très
très beau
tu voudras il parle
encore ils vont grimper du caméléon tony
epône dès leur
arrivée
j'ai comparé avec syracuse ouais ce qui
est certain et ce qui est intéressant
aussi herman le disais c'est le
lendemain que disaient aussi
fondamentaux en carmelo anthony à
syracuse il dribble et pas comme ça une
clique de bakambu djhero
fait aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
qu'il a déjà donc il ya déjà un petit
peu d'avancé
là mais après c'est des choses il ce
travail contrairement à
l'explosif travail aussi oui moi parce
que là actuellement tu as un jour qu'il
ya 106 kilos de métaux ce qui déjà très
lourds très effectivement très développé
je le trouve pas encore hyper
hyper raffinés c'est encore un jour que
je trouve encore il ya encore des choses
à travailler ce jour là sur la
musculature là dessus pour le côté
explosivité sur du faisceau moi j'aime
bien quand même le soupçon sa capitale
changé de main dans son dribble
notamment quand il est près du panier
jour du post posté au poste bas capacité
à vite et faire un reversement donc
après cette la question c'est est ce
qu'il pourra avoir la même chose en nba
il ya c'est un genre qui beaucoup jour
du poste bas
ont ils si elle est ce qu'on aime bien
on lui donnera les mêmes ballon sachant
qu'on est dans une victime - le mi
distance et le titre à trois points
c'est pas encore sa plus grande force et
ça ça peut peut-être poser problème au
début sur son adaptation son ajustement
au niveau supérieur
je suis je fais c'est là je suis assez
d'accord sur sur cette partie là en fait
il a un rapport de mes rapports de
puissance qui est tellement tellement
favorable pour lui par rapport à ce
qu'il fait c'est un mec est très fort
sur tout ce qui est surtout l'esprit
vraiment vraiment tourner sur les deux
épaules il peut quasiment fier des deux
même si des actes peu la balance en fait
ce qui n'a pas forcément sur l'explorer
sur la vitesse pure il va le gagner sur
l'inertie parce que je les ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est un bus et puis parce
qu'elle il ya des vraies qualités il ya
un peu de finesse dans son jeu il ya un
peu de 15 ans le même s'il va un peu
tout droit qui est beaucoup sur des jams
top être capable d'être sûre du open
d'abord de passer dessous d'aller
chercher dame à gauche et ainsi de suite
moi c'est les choses qui m'ont assuré
puis puis encore une fois physiquement
lui on peut le jeter dans le grand bain
demain je pense qu'il est lié pendant
d'être prêt d'être comme billy la
différence est la difficulté 21 en
défense parce que on sent que ça manque
de vécu on sent qu'il peut être pas une
grosse latéralité encore mais ça reste
ça arrive ça reste un joueur un joueur
très intéressant puis elle contexte duke
je pense qu'il faut pas les choses qu'on
ne voit pas de porc le gros cette année
on les a vus à au lycée à od où il était
porteur de balle créateur là il fait
surtout du fait de la création
secondaire c'est à dire on lui donne la
balle en mouvement et non de prendre une
décision il a bien fait j'ai beaucoup
aimé ces derniers mois et fait converger
avec les kick out qu'il a fait la vision
que les shooteurs dans les coins j'étais
vraiment je les ai pas assez vu cette
année ce que je vais devoir aller parler
de tatum about à tout le monde ceux qui
avaient raté tatum c'est parce qu'ils
avaient trop focus le contexe duke parce
que avant la lui faire d'autres choses
qu'on avait pas vu faire donc sur banque
héros et j'aime franchement j'aime mais
normalement le profil juste dans cette
grave j'ai personne que joie est au
numéro 1 d'une équipe qui peut aller au
titre donc c'est pour ça que je pense
que ventes et on veut pas de ce jour là
donc je pense que chet par rapport à lui
on va m'apporter des 40 défensive depuis
et de spacing à trois points sur pick'n
pay comme choses comme ça ils seront
bien qu'ils seront plus plus importante
je pensais peut-être même plus rare à
trouver peut-être le profil de chez tom
graines à on aime beaucoup parler oui il
ya beaucoup de plus en plus de licorne
c'est quand même mais gare à un mec qui
fait 2,15 et d'envergure projeté 2,30
qui cette année à 37% à 3 points sont
quasiment trois tentatives fort match
épique le faire des passes c'est rare
quand quéro serra aussi un mec de son
rapport poids taille qui peut faire mal
de choses mais j'avoue que c'est un peu
moi on retrouve plus tiens juste pour
parce qu'on aime bien parler d'une
plante de l'entourage et que saqqara
souvent il ya une décla qui m'a fait
beaucoup rire de la part des départs en
deux deux pans de banksy roa aquatique
est il leur dit alors je retrouve la
citation excusez-moi sous les yeux
il est à vous faites sur ce que vous
voulez si vous voulez qu'on voulait
mettre des coups de pied au cul en
espérant donc si j'aime bien le fait qu'
on n'est pas bien tu
sais bien qu'on reconnaît des parents
qu'ils soient pas dans la starification
de leur petit et qui créa vrai
professionnel et qu'il met le coach au
dessus de tout on a souvent des jeunes
qui arrivent et qui se star et filles
eux-mêmes et qu'ils se mettent vraiment
au dessus du collective au dessus du du
staff et ses bonnes quiros un jour de
moules c'est un joueur que tu vas
pouvoir façonner que je pense qu'il y
aura une très bonne mentalité et ça
aussi jamaica les travaille avec au
niveau du passif a quand même un
contexte sport puce plus entre le père
et la mère cage ou en w le biais
d'un contact il ya un terrain favorable
il ya un terreau comme on dit
et et c'est d'ailleurs un des points
communs
aux trois joueurs que moi j'ai dans mon
tient un jeu pensé
j'y vois pas de melon
c'est en réalité witch est un
fondu dans le truc il voulait je pense
surtout gagner des fois il n'a pas fait
trop de stats
s'il fallait c'est la lumière à d'autres
journées de la fin des voitures d'accord
le contexte du stade à fait d'accord
avec ce que tu disais à la naissance
blanche contexte de jeu collectif je
trouve que ça joue bien sauf que il ya
un gros rhume preneur il ya des mecs qui
savent à peu près de créer
sont et surtout qu'ils sont en fait très
intelligent défense là où on lui fait
part en même temps les efforts et autour
de lui dire que des gens qui font les
efforts défensivement il qui jouent aux
consoles
mais c'est vrai mais il n'a pas alarmant
la balle qu'il aurait pu la voir dans
d'autres contextes du sac je voulais
aussi on pense à lyon dans premier choix
de draft bas on préfère contrôler un mec
je pense pas qu'il va donner le ballon
sur pas mal de procès ça peut vous
détendre chez que j'avais fait un petit
peu de bruit c'était on l'a souvent vu
sortir pour des crampes par le bond
cayron est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui vous inquiète un petit peu sur son
physique ou c'est quelque chose qui va
se réguler et que ces
guides je sais qu il disait qu'il
n'était pas habité mais c'est parfois de
perdre 4-0 par match
moi ça ne tient pas du tout le staff ont
sa faveur
oui exactement
dur tout n'est cependant
des grands blocs de sel dans le top10
tiers faire
donc on est d'accord comme une graine
banques et rochers tout le monde c'est
entre ses seins et 1 et 2 peu près mois
sur son binôme là après il ya une
question
c'est perrine you thank un patriote de 2
à l'aigle visiblement qui leur est le
patronyme qui demande que ce que donnera
du grain dans des attaques sur pick'n
roll pour moi aujourd'hui c'est pas des
serments ce plu dans le pick n pop ça
peut être intéressant de pick and roll
je sais pas s'il a vraiment la capacité
à des sandales impacté les joueurs sur
des sur des cils et verrouiller un petit
peu par contre dans une rare attaque qui
sera articulée autour de pick and roll
avec de la mobilité comme c'est un
joueur du mouvement c'est quelque chose
qui peut être intéressant par contre
attendre sur du pick and go classique je
pose l'écran je roule je verrouille j'y
crois moins mais une attaque
un système plus ouvert comme ça qu'il
voulait un petit peu plus pourquoi pas
finir au cercle sur pick'n roll pas tout
de suite passé de ça c'était son pick
and roll plus
[Musique]
cherche en 3d peut être dangereux et sur
papa outil peut être dangereux aussi et
est ce que est ce que tu sais tu as
presse un truc que naquit trouve sur
côté ou pas un débat qu'on a plusieurs
fois est ce que vous le trouvez qu'il
est agressif est ce que vous trouvez que
quand l'équipe elle a besoin qui step up
il va allez pouvoir prendre du ballon et
et justement aller marquer des points ce
que peuvent faire peut-être le les deux
autres mais qu'on va avoir dans le tiers
1 en début de tiers 2 de prendre des
responsabilités
là dessus à son agressivité je la trouve
défensivement
c'était un fou furieux et mais
offensivement il me semble que c'est ce
monsieur
alors qu'aurel races et les prix des
crêpes à répétition avant il y a tourné
une dernière fois et il est dit aura
pris la 5ème
je suis sûr je suis un joueur de ce
profil quand on est capable de prendre
un rebond défensif et pousser le ballon
quand on est capable d'aller au rebond
quand on est capable à certains moments
de poser la balle au sol et créer pour
les autres il faut un peu la gracilité
ainsi non produit rien et vu ce qu'il
produit dans le jeu globalement
on se pourrait qu'un manque
d'agressivité comme tu dis défensivement
défensivement il est présent toute façon
que tu tu n'as pas une capacité à
bloquer les tirs ou à changer les tirs
si t'es pas capable en termes de
coordination en termes de lecture en
termes d'anticipation donc dans le
comportement de recherche d'agressivité
de faire ces choses je pense pas que les
contrats sont pas agressifs c'est celle
ci y en a mais c'est parce que c'est pas
le meilleur et puis alan tu tu me coûte
si je dis des bêtises mais ce n'était
pas forcément non plus son rôle dans la
hiérarchie de gonzague quant à jimmy
ouais comme non c'est une équipe
expérimentée
lui c'est le ces jeunes c'est la jeune
voyage à la jeune pépite mais
moi je suis moi je te regarde peut-être
qu'on ne joue qu il aurait pu un moment
même temps ils déclarent plus que ça à
l'intérieur c'est plus compliqué pour
lui que pour band cheyrou smith pas de
dire à donner moins de ballons je vais
crosser ou alors faire une action qui
m'ont peut-être que je suis super
agressive il ya plus falloir qu'on
utilisera sur un pied droit qui tiennent
pas compte comme ça donc il est aussi
dépendant un peu la création des autres
si il ya d'autres il ya d'autres
systèmes qui semblait par marc few il
peut encore pâtir mais
moi je ne me pose pas de problème l'ol
je le trouvais très positif le la
mentalité une chute est d'ailleurs ce
que bien des rares annonces apportent à
la question de deux bus mma
compatriotes
et
dans une équipe où des trois essais on
est une équipe pourrie mais cet emblème
il a quand même deux points
comme porteur de balle assez correct il
ya une usure du pick and roll mais comme
toute intérieure et comme tout le toit
mais le nez dans une équipe on pense
aussi mais très vite mais il y en a au
moins un par équipe et c'est bientôt
l'heure de jeu car moi aussi c'est pour
ça que tu as je te disais que je
descendais forcément par rapport à un
porteur de balle c'est que si tu as une
équipe qui est pourri qui arrive pas à
recruter un ou bien à trouver une autre
pépite arrière qui peut porter le ballon
efficacement
peut-être que tu auras un retard de
développement ce jour là et ça sans
stream ont peur oui en ce moment mais
c'est une équipe pourrie directement et
augmente taton plafond défensivement on
a vu evans meubler un qui a changé une
défense et comme il y est l'homme mobley
il peut jouer avec un autre intérieur
qui ne tirent pas c'est tout davantage
de certaines graines comme terry jackson
daté l'était avant parfois les gens dont
on attend beaucoup il est question à il
est trop il m'a dit oui les filles un
physique de crevette ou des choses comme
ça oui mais comme une expérience ascom
pasqua me dire il tu peux le mettre avec
un mec plus lourd et donc qui ne tirent
pas il sera pas le mec qui tire pas sur
le terrain et rêve ça pour moi ça nous
donne un très très bon potentiel c 'est
lesparraine connais je dis tu peux poser
le problème à l'envers si fédérer il a
besoin d'avoir un honneur un porteur de
balle fort mais à quel point lui barrant
le porteur de balle chez déjà plus fort
également sa robe la menace par le fait
qu'ils sachent
partie de cette génération
le prime nage ou en intérieur mais des
gens comprennent pas c'est encore une
fois on exactement comme travail sur les
petites catégories puisque les gens de
là et 2 ont pris grand mais il est nul à
12-13 ans sur les joueurs intérieurs
surtout sur des profils à 2,15 comme ça
le prime c'est quoi 27 28 ans dark là
aujourd'hui on est sûr on est sur un
joueur qui est qui et à quoi 2002 qui va
qui va arriver à ses 20 ans cette année
pas mal d'années qui vient 2022
il a il a quand même une marge devant
lui qui est énorme si vous rappelez
nowitzki quand il doit racheter tout le
monde rigole corps d'élite comme ces
drafté les gens se demandent ce que
c'est sûr qu'à un moment laissé le temps
aux grands se développer
la question c'est ce qui est l'acquéreur
pour prendre du poids je pense qu'à un
moment de toute façon quand on fait 2 15
conte à la mobilité qui là ce sera
jamais un joueur qui ne sera jamais
dolph lungren pour les plus anciens en
termes de référence à un joueur dragon
musculeux mais c'est quelqu'un qui peut
devenir solide et épaissir le cadre
inévitablement parce qu'encore une fois
les qualités motrices qui la font de
toute façon il apprendra - également
elle se sera jamais quelqu'un de poli
biden mais derrière derrière ces excuses
et à l'heure on est on est sur un quatre
et demi en fait il sera pas vraiment
quatre normalement 5 entre les deux on
est sûre du basket entre guillemets
moderne et sûre du c'ur du positionner
ce typique avec lui mais il ya soyez pas
pressé de mike est drafté demain les
saignantes autant exactement la question
fera de la même façon déguisée avec avec
victor hedman là-bas l'an prochain est
ce qui va prendre un moment un outil va
prendre du volume oui laisser du temps
aux gens laisser du temps aux gens pour
se développer on est sur une course au
allen d'année sur une course au plus tôt
n'est d'en acheter mieux celle sauf
qu'on oublie que le développement des
gens promu temps est long mais encore
une fois sur les joueurs d'exception
quoi commander et peut-être que ça va me
contredire mais il ne semble pas qu'il y
ait de
[Musique]
blessures historiques qu'ils soient
inquiétantes pour shenzhen ce qui est
déjà un très très positif
moi le champ bas du corps est déjà bien
d'en jouer tout le temps dominé juste la
petite question pour le fait au moins on
peut prendre du poids peut-être mais
voilà on l'a de romain l'a dit il c'est
du police mais si peu aussi de défendre
très bon sur deuxième rideau donc en
gros si jamais tu te fait défendable
d'intérieur plus puissante et plus petit
qui va faire une pause d'un pays peut
faire la tour de contrôle après et il ya
je trouve une super polyvalent ce
potentiel avec lui qui est qui est
possible avec un biais donc il ya des
questions c'est normal mais on est en
2002 22 on est donc encore on est
persuadé mais je n'en n'ai pu en
nombreuses marques nouvelle
série de prix n'est pas facile de
s'adapter
années dans un combat gars
c'est la pierre angulaire du système en
sachant que c'est une fac c'est ce que
c'est c'est des icônes comme villanova
ou comme d'autres ou un moment ou un
autre on sait globalement que les
joueurs qui passent sont en termes de qi
basket toujours un petit peu plus avancé
que la moyenne même s'il ya des
exceptions bien sûr à d et des abrutis
comme partout mais
c'est pas des facs on va quand on est
quand on n'est pas capable de comprendre
et d'apprendre justement pour ceux qui
ont peur de sa capacité à gérer le
contact il ya deux mois ce qu'on peut
être conseillé celui contre texas eu des
rencontres très mitchell qui est un
pivot petit mais très très très puissant
très musculeux il le gère totalement et
si vous avez l'occasion de regarder le
match contre le canada ont eu 19 will
defend contrat qui dit le pivot énorme
google code de tours diu
alors iti fait un bon match mais tu y es
tu finis comme le meilleur joueur du
match et il met six blocs et voilà qui
tient vraiment un très gros pivot donc
ça peut renaître mais aussi même si
aucun cas n'était font le compte par
williams mark williams est
sérieux il ya de l'opposition à regarder
pour vous rien que ça moi je pense que
ce qu'il faut regarder d'en haut niveau
de la deûle à karl dans la capacité à
prendre du poids est l'exemple typique
pour moi c'est rudy gobert qui arrivé
qu'à physique aussi tous faim
et qui va ajouter du poids sans
ordonnance
non plus mais de façon intelligente tout
en gardant justement sa mobilité qui est
aussi sa force notamment défensives
après on n'est pas sur la même finesse
technique donc d'autant les chances que
physiquement
c'est un peu la marche à suivre entre
guillemets on pense à ce qu'on veut de
la 26ème et un mec qui est trop fort il
peut pas jouer en 6 e hier j'ai fait un
instrument on a parlé de marcus bingham
qui est le pivot de michigan state pour
ceux qui le connaissent dans trois ans
donc c'est un gros prospects pendant
trois ans et la page mais parce qu'ils
étaient 90 kg trop trop faim il fait
tout le temps faute cette année là prit
enfin du poids il peut jouer et donc
sinon tu peux pas répondre trois ans une
scie et c'est comme quand même le poids
est important donc si chat y jouer qui
domine c'est que il est assez bordel on
a des infos l'aquila et retient on sait
combien il est sur la balance le gardon
mais il est un peu moins de 100 kg je
pense
alors
oui c'est loupé deux jours
lorsque sursis j'ai 88 ch ou google donc
avec une très belle question est-ce que
611 jeunes strong est ce qu'ils voient
les vraies questions sur google est ce
qu'ils les ford il a pris du poids
qu'elle tarifs est et ce qui se fait là
j'ai eu m 100 kg développer c'est la
plus belle de toutes est ce que c'est un
prospect nba
les vraies questions sont sur
généralement les trois premières années
90 kg mais ça me paraît un peu un pari
entre la pharmacie et
messieurs il va histoires de on va on va
enchaîner avec peut-être le plus ou
moins le troisième larron selon les
goûts et les visions on va dire je sais
que ça va être peut-être un petit peu
clivant on va parler de diama des barry
smith
alan je te laisse commencé à et que dieu
bénisse d'auburn ouais
en fait c'est marrant parce que j'étais
peut-être un des plus chauds voudrait
barry smith avant la saison mais je
trouve que là ça
sa part peut-être que trop c'est trop
trop chaud là
quand je le quand je le vois voilà
numéro un des big board unanime la gérer
j'ai un peu de mal moi j'adorais déjà
par l'ex-miss parce que je crois qu'il
ya un joueur qui pouvait tirer comme ça
à son poids rien que ça ça m'intéresse
moi ça m'intéresse on l'avait vu dans
les catégories jeunes il y avait un
super mémés envergure écrit sur des
mairies smith en juin 2010 9 ans on
était un peu avant tout le monde c'était
après le fiba du 16e sommet rica
je crois qu'un joueur a que cette
capacité de tirer
sa taille le fait qu' il a une bonne
mentalité qu'il se déplace plutôt bien
il est plutôt fluide balle en main ça
m'intéresse bref pour ça je l'avais
assez haut je les ai mis au je l'aï vu
que j'aime vraiment personne très très
haut dans cet ordre au point d'avoir
quelqu'un tout ce dont j'ai rajouté de
jabbar excuse parce qu'un mec a deux qui
quasiment à deux disques qui peut tirer
je pense à flux à haut volume à trois
points bas c'est quelque chose
d'intrigant d'élite et donc je le mets
là mais par contre le diable harry smith
compense ultra dominant
je ne sais pas vraiment le cas le
cabaret smith polyvalent défensivement
je les trouve pas très polyvalent
défensivement donc voilà je pense faire
un petit peu calmé la méga hype mais ça
reste un excellent spectacle
peut-être qu'il faut rappeler que ça un
pivot qui shoote à 45 % 23 points
voilà voilà quand on aime on aime aussi
pour ça une faute elle 50 indique
qu'il a lens on tient pas
mais non c'est vous
je crois que j'en redemande à
la nuit ça le tien et de nouve dire oui
pour l'instant mais je suis circonspect
pour moi lui les plus proches du 4 que
tu 2 chez moi il est fière d'eux et je
les plus proches du quatrième que du
deuxième parce que je crois pas qu mois
encore ce truc là mais qu'ils puissent
teneur du ballon qu'ils puissent un peu
voilà prendre des responsabilités balle
en main et de la moi forcément je vais
le tester j'aime beaucoup le joueur mais
le je trouve que le potentiel est pas
non plus si démentielle que ça sera un
jour très fort il peut être star mais
voilà je joue je vois pas un porteur de
bonnes joues pas un franz player je vois
pas ce que peut être une équipe pourrait
rechercher à ce niveau-là ça que c'est
parce qu'on trouve encore se couper les
cheveux en quatre voir des mecs
mais je laime forme et je me calme petit
écran
robin je sais qu'il a visionné tu aimes
tu as sorti le bail au bilan bien c'est
pas pour rien ouais ouais non
toujours toujours fait voilà qui met des
maillots des maillots de bain idole de
jeunesse avec moi
je les regardais jouer un petit peu
je suis je suis très utilisé sur le
garçon
parce que autant il ya quelque chose
d'intéressant physiquement je pense que
c'est pareil il est long il est il est
pas loin d'être nba reli après un peu
peur sur ses choix parfois même si
statistiquement oui me gâche peu et
qu'il est assez il est assez efficace
mais je trouve qu'il insiste beaucoup
sur le terrible secret pas forcément
énormément d'espacé sur ce que j'en ai
vu
voilà très grand fan du contact qu'il y
ait beaucoup de sueur le pouleuf sur ces
choses là je me demande s'il a un volant
ou s'il est vraiment tout le temps de
sous contrôle c'est
je pense que comme comme comme action
secondaire sur n'importe quelle équipe
qui aurait à son poste ça peut être
intéressant mais je suis je suis très
mesurée en fait le joueur est
intéressant mais je suis très mesuré
c'est moi ce qui me ce qui m'a ce qui
m'a fait tiquer si cette capacité
alors il ya des feintes et du soft
chalet chose intéressante mais le fait
de pas se créer des espaces et de
prendre des tiers souvent compliqué
souvent contestées
c'est pas quelque chose qui me rassure
en prêt pourcentage qui l'a fait qu'il a
raison des cours qu'il est maintenant ok
pas de souci mais voilà je garde un
point d'interrogation
tiret apple surtout ce tir part à
matignon prend que deux cents près du
panier
on parlait des questions google tout à
l'heure
ça m'a fait marrer quand romain a dit et
s qui joue tout en sous contrôle parce
que la première chose que j'ai écrit
quand j'ai vu jouer de larry smith et
eskil à plusieurs vitesses
on parle souvent d'un procès fait à une
deux ou trois vitesses c'est à dire
est-ce que plus le joueur sous contrôle
est ce que tu peux jouer vite en
transition est ce que tu peux très vite
et lui tu as l'impression que
la troisième elle un peu de mal
c'est c'est super intéressant parce que
souvent en attendant se trouve dans
l'utilisation des statistiques là tout
le monde met en avant le concept à
d'autres pointent java respect ça fait
deux mois que fait tout le monde et
c'est vrai il prend des tirs super
compliqué et y met il met 45% à 3 points
surtout de cinq points par match pour un
mec à 2,8 de 18 ans c'est totalement
anormal il faut le dire ça prouve
qualité de tir à vue il ya par contre il
faut pas mettre lille et il est et
s'impose groupe grand problème il a 44 %
à 2 points comment ça s'explique va
comme la digue il finit pas au cercle
des petits fini très peu au cercle
attendait beaucoup d'eux midrange
contestées beaucoup de sacs à son jeu où
je le vois il est en situation de post
qui préfèrent faire interne à rendre
très compliqué plutôt que d'aller je
crois du panier pourquoi parce que je
pense que c'est dans sa tête un bac
schumaker ils seront pour un très fort
c'est un très fort shooteur je pense
mais ça dort pas empêché du fait que
même les méga shooter ils ont des moyens
de scorer facilement c'est un truc je
trouve qu'on souccot complètement montre
moi ce que tu fais facilement monte moi
ce que tu fais au pourcentage et c'est
vrai que sur jabbari smith tout à l'air
un peu parfois
contestées un peu compliqué et donc ça
avait un je pense un peu ça va rentrer
en compte dans son évaluation je pense
avoir entre en compte dans son évocation
29% mes distances avec trois cartes de
couleur voilà il est beaucoup dans sa
réalité dans un système à auburn aussi
on a ri ce rappel l'année dernière moi
j'aimais beaucoup territoire ça mais
c'est un système s'est vraiment bien
mettre en avant des grands capable de
direct du space in gilad est porteur de
balle si vous voulez mais tant elle a lu
il ya pas de spécial dans ce qu'il fait
c'est ça le problème c'est ça il pourra
y prendre 10 prend des poules alors ça
choque charte on peut partager des
images ou pas pierre sur-le-champ live
je ne sais pas mais bon je
suis si content
[Musique]
et twitch avec alan et il
envoie la charte comme ça si si
quelqu'un se sont tentées mais le truc
chartres et les mets la dans le lien du
chat privé moi je l'aï fait sur youtube
derrière en plus il voit là ils jouent
comme gucci je pense comment ça valait
rien que la touche arty joue avec walker
kessler qui est un géant
protecteur de cercle et qui chuta si tu
commences à shooter d'ailleurs il lui
dit je t'ai pas amoindri shoot donc
jabbari smith n'est jamais le poste je
trouvais déjà j'ai pratiquement jamais
vu le poste 5 de l'équipe donc il ya des
séquences quand même mais il joue avec
un autre intérieur offensivement mais
pas de nouvelles choses comme ce que
voilà et moi je trouve que il faut quand
même au temps soit son profil offensif
incroyable qu'ils et qui me faisait
saliver avant l'année qui faisait ce qui
fait saliver tout le monde mais c'est
normal aussi parlé du du côté défensif
il est pas mal dans l'interception sur
les contacts qui peut être un petit peu
il a une envergure bonne mais pas
incroyable je pense que pour un
intérieur comporte très haut le
potentiel la défense il doit être plus
plus sinon c'est un peu ça peut être un
peu compliqué on parle quand l on parle
de joueurs dominants gel il ya une seule
qui fonctionne très bien un traître est
à dire qui est un très très bête c'est
le taux de lancers francs
et si tu regardes les
15 dernières années je crois qu'ils ont
battus j'ai regardé les joueurs draftés
dans le top 10 cadets 1 un taux de
lancers francs inférieur à 30% comme job
les seuls résultats qui ressortent et
des spécialistes c'est
long deux couples qui n'allait pas au
cercle pour des raisons
diamal murray oggi maillot freshman nick
stokes casse michael ritchie voilà ce
que dit que des joueurs qui font 15 cm
de moins que tu as parisse mais c'est
parce qu'il un skill cette offensive qui
n'est pas celui qui devra avant avec sa
taille alors c'est très positif mais ça
pose aussi des questions le l'exception
est dedans
wagner
qui avait racheté l'année dernière et
qui bêlent saison
pendant dos mais qu'à d'autres qualités
qu'on n'a pas encore vu tout à fait pour
moi chez smith notamment les rotations
de hanche l'intelligence
expansive aussi même si même si
après wagner jeu pondère toujours un
petit peu parce que même s'ils jouaient
peu avec l'alba berlin il a eu deux
trois ans de professionnalisme avant
d'arriver en entier et je pense que dans
le développement c'est toujours quelque
chose qui peut qui peut être utile
surtout sur des profils comme ça a été
dit emballé zimmer mouvement
il ya une chose qu'on n'a pas dit c'est
que c'est vrai je sais pas si c'est lui
mais il n'est pas loin d'être le plus
jeune candidat
s'est pas réfugié
est prêt dans une petite high school
petit championnat
n'était pas la qualité d'opposition
qu'il a eu à affronter pas été
incroyable
peut-être que ça peut jouer mais doit on
parler de déplacement latéral etc moi je
trouve que ça bon sain qui ne pourra pas
jouer quatre pour moi il ya ce problème
de hanche que tu à noter que je pense
faut en parler c'est qu'à chaque
changement de direction il est battu en
fait qu'à chaque rame est retrouvé à
devoir contesté latéralement un ailier
même pas un gardien mais un ailier et
que le lit est capable de changer de
mains de changer de direction assez
brutalement diab avait spécifié dans le
vent
moi je ne vois pas comment aujourd'hui
on peut le projeter sur lui chaque un
non sens pas songé un moment on peut
être toujours du sac pas du tout jours
d'un vote sur la motion qu'ils font pas
assez de rebond il protège pas ses biens
zéro
alors il est où le talent y est le
problème le problème c'est quoi tu me
regardes jouer il est tout le temps
large et meilleur temps il tire
tellement bien que c'est pas grave parce
que tu peux le mettre avec 1,5 qui y
sera là pour faire entre guillemets à
être proche de la peinture et tout ça
c'est pour ça que je l'aimé bien parce
qu'il t'a porte quand même beaucoup de
polyvalence et aux portions de ccc ce
cas là encore une fondée sur demande et
sur un quatre et demi sur la définition
qu'on a parce que si on lui a si on
regarde les chiffres la chaude charte
mais qui ne sert quasiment autant en 3ka
2 si la plus grosse activité en bref ils
consacrent est il une grosse agressivité
par l'emprunt du cher mais beaucoup la
balle au sol un peu de post up moi moi
je tue montre une vidéo tu ne montres
avec o'byrne sans me dire quel poste il
joue jamais je te lis que 5 je vous ai
mis à voler dans le chatt normalement
après comme il disait à l'âne c'est
qu'il faut toujours avec dylan cordoue
elle ouvre kirk et ce lors qu'ils sont
des mecs qui peuvent pas écarter le jeu
et qu'à chaque fois qu'il avait fait
vrai qu'il a dû défoncer sur des
couvertures de pick and roll qui
l'adulent europe et il a toujours est
excellent je trouve moi j'ai pas mal de
clips la soul et sous les yeux contre
différentes équipes à chaque fois qu'il
a dû être bon et latéralement et qu' il
tient son extérieur comme ça qu'il
l'envoie au panier chaque fois il le
prend ils ont une famille eux aussi en
devant une zone près d'1 3 1 où un deuil
comme ça où il est les voilà dans la
dissuasion dans les choses comme ça
bailly c'est un classique heures 20
le le grand pas forcément
le plus véloce
mais mais mais beaucoup de places de
maisons mais rarement leone mais ramon
l'egypte devant c'est plutôt les tons de
vert en général un peu comme ça que ça
se passe je fais organisation tactique
mais maintenant c'est c'est assez
spécifique au basket universitaire est
simple en europe et beaucoup au jeune
cirque balles et les gens les plus les
plus longs mais qui peuvent aussi
parfois être se sont conclues dans les
rainures sens général son compère ce
qu'on met devant pour ralentir après moi
moi ce que j'en ai vu quand il défend
des sur des joueurs qui étaient pas des
charges c'est quand même un mec qui est
un petit peu limité
en deux mots là que tu défends des kill
switch et beaucoup qui était beaucoup
touché par les écrans moi j'ai des j'ai
vraiment des géants des beaucoup de
points d'interrogation sur lui sur ce
qu'il peut faire et je suis justement le
cas quel poste il peut le faire
c'est pour ça que je te disais tout à
l'heure pierre mans il est sur un tir
point entièrement très fragile mais tire
un parce qu'il est jeune parce qu'il a
pas beaucoup connu de haut niveau normal
qu'ils se prennent des baffes aussi haut
au début
mai
mais ça va être ça va être tout par
exemple celle que l'on parlait de
shenzhen qui est pareil un peu long je
pense que l'adaptation en nba elle sera
très rapide offensivement silva avant
lui demande juste de faire tir mais pour
justifier un top-5 grave japon
est-ce qu'on se rappelle à quel niveau a
été drafté deux pays et washington
ont ce salon
nous parce que c'est quand même un type
de joueur dont la taille est dans le
style de jeu tir de loin qui fait
beaucoup penser quand même mais les plus
grands noms a pris des washington mila
demain
ouverte de m 0,1 pour le prévoit la loi
mais on est plus sur un cap quand même
sur pied
voilà c'est débute par rapport à ça
justement
avoir quatre ou cinq pas dire que c'est
un projet qui là aussi c'est à dire que
certains joueurs ont finalement
l'impression qu'ils savent pas trop où
le mettre si on intervient surtout
défensivement dernier saxon pour par
exemple
l année où katie washington belz
vachement on est rock king
il avait un rôle limité
ouais c'était un trip avec cette équipe
avec chen hawks et tous c'était horrible
pour les intérieurs
le truc c'est que si tu prends pour moi
si tu le prends 4 tu le prends pas dans
le top 6 cette suite parce qu'il pourra
pas défendre en nba sur ce qu'on ne va
attendre des postes 4 actuellement il
faut le prendre pour moi uniquement 5
c'est le nombre était dur jackson tu
pensais qu'il pouvait dépendre il fait
un peu
mieux il bouge tout comme une grâce et
une âme et une vraie latéralité ses
parents il posait pas je vais xavier
lemoine et où il y as well
as the way i feel man aussi moi je
trouve qu'il bougeait un peu moins bien
que maintenant je pense que ça peut
s'améliorer
pour moi jahren jackson était comme avec
comme plus de deux caractéristiques de
joueurs intérieurs dans ce qu'il
montrait les que de deux ans que l'on
déjà barry smith et encore une fois le
son son espèce de poulpe éternel moi je
veux bien il met dedans mais le skill
scène pour moi il ya déjà des choses que
je comprends pas par rapport à la
projection qu'on en fait après que me
trompe peut-être sûrement mal
c'est un profil étrange et c'est pour ça
que c'est intéressant moi je les tiens
juste parce que tu es un simple jeu
crasher de tirs à trois points cette
taille là je trouve que c'est super
value et benoît toutes les équipes en
voudront on parle souvent de bouc lopez
comme quoi toutes les équipes ont besoin
conclut lopez n'importe quelle franchise
nba devant une équipe pour pouvoir
avoir du specis maxime
la création
du pôle
amont pa soir
salle elle aussi le fait que vive
la fois
c'est
son bébé passe à allumer
les vues crosser ligne de fond partir du
15 août allez on va l'opposer
franchement pour sa taille et son âge
c'était ça fait maintenant il finit fils
fait les choses techniquement qui sont
propres je me dis encore une fois mais
pour moi ce que le problème que j'ai
c'est la projection par rapport au poste
c'est à dire que
cinq jeux j'y crois pas 4 pourquoi pas à
venir les choses qui manquent et 3 ça va
pas assez vite un oncle donc donc donc
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui pour moi les
vidanges sur lui c'est plus 4 mai
dans ce cas là il va manquer des choses
on va finir donc ça c'est bon sens des
retours on a fini avec le tiers 1 je
pense qu'il ya personne qui a nui 1 qui
a highly anckière 1 je crois de mémoire
non personne donc on va passer ça fait
dix ans qu'on est ensemble on va passer
du coup au tiers 2
voilà il lui parlait de david purdue le
meneur un peu venez de twitter celui
dont on voit plus passer les rails sans
doute
est-ce que c'est le wac paraît évident
vous avez d'autres noms à proposer
en rue du tiers de ware ou du tien de
moi en tout cas c'est le joueur avec qui
j'ai dit prêt le bus pour le monter
entière avec teijin griffin mais son
début de saison mais mais sinon ouais
ben laden a émis par son premier bar sa
progression au tir sa dimension physique
sa progression wendell aussi tout ça
fait que il il peut être un jeu pensant
garde assez rapidement
en portant dans une équipe est
deuxième non je suis assez je suis assez
d'accord
[Musique]
je suis pas le plus grand fan de sa
prise de décision mais ce il est
tellement athlétique et vive qui se rend
les décisions simples en fait
c'est aussi quelque chose trouve deux
constructeurs peut-être les qualités
athlétiques c'est bien j'ai en fait
c'est faux a expliqué que ça permet à
des joueurs peut-être moins qu'ils sont
moins dans l'appréhension très jeunes de
se faciliter la tâche et lui en fait ce
pas je trouve qu'il n'est pas ce qui
n'est pas le meilleur dans
l'appréhension sur pick'n roll n'est pas
le meilleur dans l'appréhension français
mais il fait tellement de séparation de
choses un très bon système a perdu ce
qu'il faut se dire c'est une très bonne
équipe
du racing à tour ya c'est super défense
intérieur aussi énorme l'a complètement
et en même temps
ce qu'il faut noter c'est quand on a vu
dans un autre rôle fiba cet été pour moi
c'est le meilleur buteur de toute la
compétition en un mot le dit super
intéressant il bougeait bien
et donc je pense quoi il à profit les
super super complet je pense juste que
ça peut pas être un je trouve qu'il a
rien
de elite plus plus plus ça parle à ce
premier pas donc je peux pas le maître
tient mais c'est un c'est un super jeu
je suis pas d'accord avec le fait qu'il
a rien de plus que ce format serre c'est
un athlète qui peut réagir très vite
balle en main et sagesse est très fort
c'est le fait que même quand tu crois
qu'il va pas de le ballon il trouve
toujours quelque chose alors ils en
perdent des ballons et comme le dit alan
jara piqué alors le pic est pas pirates
beaucoup de passes on a fait un stream
n'est pas très longtemps on parlait de
lui il ya plein de clips où tu le voir
rater son shooteur ouvert oui genre de
choses là mais c'est un gars qui peut
partir sur les deux mains qui peut
changer de donner un petit peu changé de
vitesse qui encaisse le contact qui peut
kick
et quand il va perdre le ballon il ya
toujours une petite passe réflexe
étoiles avec plein de highlights hurler
sur des flashs qui l'a de décision qui
me font que pensait que ce jour là je
peux lui donner le ballon une bille et
en faire un créateur principal est
peut-être qu alan le colis qui croient
pas en tant que créateur principal balle
en mains d'une équipe nba comme un vrai
os l'un de leurs numéros un mineur
étaient postulat pas une taupe tiers moi
je pense que ça peut être un vrai au nez
de leur
principal d'une équipe allait il ya
beaucoup de choses là d'abord pour
rebondir sur ce que dit alan c'est vrai
quand on le voit aujourd'hui on regarde
les stats un petit peu on regarde le mec
joue et
quand on regarde les matches oui pour
moi je ne peux pas de dire ce qui fait
de bien spécifiquement à son poste
le mec qui joue c'est ils jouent ils
jouent à l'envi il voit l'intensité il
ya du gris qui a tout ce que tu veux une
vitesse qui est pas possible donc on est
un poil inverse de valeur de ce qu'ont
dit avec alex à savoir sk la deuxième
puis la troisième lui pour le coup et ce
cas la deuxième et la première c'est à
dire que qu'il ait jamais sous contrôle
ou alors il est sous contrôle dans la
vitesse tout le temps le problème c'est
qu'on a vite un côté jean alesi et c'est
gravier derrière donc
j'ai moi j'ai du matin j'ai dit j'ai du
mal en fait c'est un joueur que je
trouve super intéressant pour répondre à
ce que nous dit notre ami khiasma 59,6
en transition c++ parce que il ay là le
poulain qui va vite et puis je pense
qu'il a
il est imprévisible donc totalement
dangereux dans ce qui peut faire il ya
des choses sur marseille perfectible
mais je le vois pas avec un style
particulier et moi ce qui m'inquiète un
petit peu c'est le ratio pas et s'ils
veulent perdu qu il a alors qu'il est
dans une équipe qui joue plutôt bien et
qu'un adresse p6000 dans laquelle il met
dieu si on est dans quelque chose de
structuré et cohérent est à 3,3 passes
pour donner trois balles perdues ça
m'inquiète un peu sur la capacité du
premier porteur de balle sur l'élitisme
nba après derrière sur une équipe qui
pourrait se projeter et courir lille va
transformer un petit peu la défense en
point et cetera experts a même s'il fait
pas beaucoup d'efforts sur pick and roll
défensivement notamment voilà après
derrière la vraie question pour moi
c'est joue beaucoup à l'énergie ce qui
veut dire que l'aiguillé les souvent
dans le rouge donc c'est un pas que les
choix le jour il apprend à jouer un peu
en marchant avec des ruptures je pense
qu'il peut se taper un petit peu c'est
là où ne s'arrête la comparaison on voit
beaucoup passé avec james cameron dans
sa saison sophomore il avait déjà
c'était comme alan à 10 août chez plus
un facteur exceptionnel quelqu'un qui va
très très vite quelqu'un cian la
technique pour passer dès demain etc
mais c'est quelqu'un que ça allait faire
des changements de riz et qui par
conséquent avait une prise de décision
qui était beaucoup plus efficace à
l'époque oui j'ai pas il était à plus de
40 % de passes décisives sincère ne rien
dire il avait fléchi même si les ai dans
une petite conférence
ces chiffres complètement hallucinante
avant tout d'un coup bien que haïti n'a
pas ça et il a les mêmes questions
malgré son bon début à trois points je
trouve qu'il a les mêmes questions aux
tirs 25 ans en 3e 6e alex diamante 52
pour
moi le tipi le tir je suis d'accord avec
toi pour moi sur le pilote est un mec
c'est un joueur de vitesse
c'est des joueurs qui sur le poulain
pour plus de facilité à se mettre en
rythme pascal dribble même sur un
dribble peuvent le fait d'attraper tirer
sa mécanique et quand ils exploitent à
sa mécanique et prom du tout moi
même j'y vais il est là dessus malgré
cette fin je vais tomber c'est un jour
qui prend beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
catch and shoot un tir à trois points je
vois que ça 80 34 7 février jean-paul ce
n'est pas propre
qui sortiront pas de double donc c'est
peu en fait il est beaucoup sur des
flottilles ce nom
c'est parce que j'ai dit jeudi que lui
sur la fluidité sur le pool up il était
naturellement plus à l'aise parce qu'il
a le bris pour se mettre en route parce
que c'est pas forcément des joueurs qui
naturellement on les kahn arrêté pour
faire de la récéption tir est ce que je
dis c'est que tu le vois quand il a
arrêté sur inception tir ou même sur des
livres tout ils bougent d'un ou deux
mètres son tir est lent et saccadé et
l'exécution sur l'eau n'est pas propre
alors oui je suis d'accord il ya des yé
les sorties baseline instituée oui mais
il va toujours être sur la mobilité du
genou il a arrêté rideau et c est ce que
dialecte pour moi c'est très vrai moi ce
qui me ce qui m'interpelle c'est que son
44 6 à trois points il est intéressant
que le volume de tirer les poids des
collants et à 25,56 donc ça fait un peu
plus de 1 cela fait trois nuits par
match c'est pas un gros volume mais
c'est correct là aujourd'hui 73 pour son
lancer est pour un joueur de son profil
45 ans et en 12 matches
c'est pas s'est passé pas si fou
considérant le fait qui court beaucoup
et instituts étaient surtout 73% s'il
était fiable pour moi dans le siège sera
de mes distances astuces et rejoint que
quand ils voient se crée son propre tir
à mi distance il a 27 % de réussite
aujourd'hui deux points l'on avait 0
passe décisive donc c'est pas un joueur
qui encore très à l'est on se crée son
propre tir avec un dribble et ensuite
élevé pour prendre un shoot pull-ups
qu'on va attendre un porteur de balle
principal en une pièce ce que faisait
déjà maurenn tu comme comparaison n'est
plus peut-être sur un car la zac la
ville même si ça revient pas malade nan
actuel n green pour des joueurs très
athlétiques ils vont très vite mais qui
va falloir développer le la propreté
balle en main pour créer ballon c'est
pour ça qu'il s'agit de jeux open courte
et de l'énergie j'aimais dg mais des
réserves sur la capacité à avoir le mur
en face de lui il a joué de mika jah man
rendent savait le faire là dessus il y
avait hier
il était capable
le coach de bourges à l'époque très
longtemps olivier hirsch là qui a gagné
l'euroligue bourges je dis bien tout le
travail qui avait marqué quand j'étais
jeune coach il est que le basket c'est
sa plainte s'est vite l'an vite ya
toujours ces trois temps si on va tout
le temps envie tout tout le temps
doucement cc c'est compliqué ou alors on
est capable de jouer en marchant mais
c'est les joueurs d'exception c'est
laurent sciarra qui joue en marchant
vers a joué en marchant tout le temps
qui quand il fallait que c'est là un
petit peu il a accéléré un petit peu
mais quand même sur du standing de
malheur de jeu niveau international et
quelque part à la capacité à gérer les
rythmes de toute façon là on est sur un
profil type du du 2 qui joue en fait par
la force des choses et dans les faits ce
que c'est pas plus 1 2 est ce que c'est
moi + 1/2 ou 1/4 va rien je pense
je pense que ce dessin la question en
fait j'étais son combat qu'on veut en
faire un porteur de ballon alors que si
ça se trouve ça serait un très très bon
sac la ville
où les joueurs
ont commencé leur carrière
finisseur définition du genre à blida
je pense que là sur le tir la réalité
elle est entre ses mains un genre qui à
44 % 3 points mais c'était pas un jour
31 25% l'an dernier la variété est née
entre les deux je pense c'est sec ça ça
s'est illustrée par le personnage
devancé frank l'a pas forcément
augmenter par rapport sur les deux
saisons j'avais entendant un danger dans
un article c'était un bon pour il y
avait des très bon pourcentage à 3
points au lycée sur pas mal de volume il
était à la lumière donc à laisser à ses
références et que même dans l'indiana
donc le tiers
c'est c'est essentiel si on veut on veut
en faire un porteur de balle je pense
que c'est pas pour ça je cette année
sont pas révélatrices de ce qu'est le
tir de ben ali aujourd'hui par contre
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure beaucoup
de soucis d'enjeu mais tu achètes comme
un matériel très intéressant à polir
contre tout type d qui est un cadre
familial plus plus plus qu'au rythme
avec notamment la maman qui est coach
actuellement
notre dame je crois et qui voit là et
qui était aussi jose wnba et voilà un
entourage sportif de diva maman maman
qui était assistant coach à mieux
classés
que moi c'était un petit peu ma question
est ce que c'est un porteur de ballon
nba
ce roman est ce que vous regardez
je regarde immédiatement est-ce qu'il
est fort c'est la question qui fait que
certains dont je pense que j'ai un
boulot des autres dont tiers 2/3 3
d'ailleurs à la clope tu es parti sur
sur griffin je crois ouais moi j'ai deux
tons tient deux gie griffin oui encore
un doux qui oui le qui pour moi
aller flash les plus
impressionnantes roue de toutes sortes
derrière les 3 mai 3 dont on parle donc
qui joue à duke qui malheureusement on
n'avait pas joué pendant un an et demi
parce que ben il s'est fait des croisés
et il s'est blessé au pied
durant donc saison junior de lycées
croisé saison
senior le pied et ensuite locaux vides
capa et d iguane c'est l'âge où
il s'est fait les croisés avant ensuite
c'est fait à cheville et le pied il ya
eu cet événement donc ça c'est sûr que
c'est pas ça on l'a vu on le voit il
joue avec des protections sur les
légendes s'est pas jouée sur l'a20
gourcuff à lyon ou qui par
année mais pour moi en fait quand je
l'avais vu il ya un an et demi deux ans
c'était le mur genre de la drogue il
avait été le plus impressionnant avec
kumming à mais que mingan et puis dans
cette offre il était père est aussi csi
reclassés à celle d'avant il est pas
mauvais en nba d'ailleurs
j'ai griffin donc c'est quasiment de m
que de 100 kg
alors qui peut passer dribbler shooter
je trouve ces puissants il est véloce
guide aussi
c'est assez impressionnant de voir un
jour je trouve que son poids est un peu
lourd parfois mais capable d'être rapide
sur ses pieds pour se sentir et il est
très très jeune il est debout août 2003
donc
je sais pas s'ils valent à la draft
pense qu'il va y aller parce que
maintenant les joueurs les joueurs ils
vont très bon niveau et parce que duke
il ya quatre cinq étoiles qui arrive
l'an prochain encore en réalité
cependant le coach voilà on va lui
demander d'y aller mais il perd un
potentiel et j'adore les potentiels
puissent plus la joie qu'ils font
oui pardon c'est un joueur qui sort
souvent du banc cette année du côté de
doug williams mais quatre fois plus de
temps de jeu là ça veut dire ça commence
a enfin le fonds censés avoir du vrai
temps de jeu garbage time et moi je lui
[Musique]
l'abondance du dixième
de ce que j'ai vu de lui c'est je trouve
ça très très impressionnant en fait la
facilité tout à l'heure en parlait de
facilité avec jabbari smith nationale
furent crétois entière facile en fait la
facilité avec laquelle ait chez griffin
pas forcément rassuré son tir pour un
concert est encore parfois compliqué
la facilité avec laquelle juste il
arrive
à partir de la lumière trois ponts est
arrivé dans la raquette tu as
l'impression qu'il n'a rien fait l'a
juste fait une petite citation d'appui
en fait il est puissant il unit les
fluides et du coup ils en kantari dans
la raquette andric ça veut dire que tu
as créé un début de pédalage et ça veut
dire
ça
c'est très très très très intéressant et
la deuxième chose c'est que je pense
vraiment que au delà n'tchengue graines
mises à part je pense que c'est le
meilleur choix le maire défenseur
potentiel de 7 pouces et
d'assez loin
voilà il est stable son parent flandin
qui jouit la dette à six points de
moyenne je crois qu'ils jouent pas
beaucoup mais je prends le con que je
pense que j'ai vu avant je pense que je
vois cette année par flash ils iraient
au draft point qui me après il ya le in
july prône d'ailleurs là je pose pas les
rapports médicaux et ont donc
jamais les choix les
forêts passer un coup de fil à côte ce
qui m est
exclue mais depuis deux ans je suis pas
sûr qu'il fera un bon duo
riz par la retraite on a un peu poussé
le bouchon
qualité palais la partie à sa dernière
année connue c'est superbe pour moi
j'applaudis partout il nous fait une
sardou ils vont faire vite
parce que sardou il revient aux [ __ ]
edgy griffin personnellement tu que je
n'ai pas mis dans mes dents non nommé
tiers parce que j'en ai pas encore assez
vu je pense que à terme je leur ai à peu
près comme alex et alan c'est jusqu'au
pour l'instant voilà ya cinq six matches
il peut regarder de j'ai pas regardé de
lycée j'ai pas regardé compétition jeune
j'aime beaucoup le les flash mais c'est
beaucoup trop tôt ne préfère m'abstenir
plutôt que dire des grosses conneries
pour une fois dans ma vie
il ya longue après le nom qui revient
plus nous somme au dodo voteront aux
deux tiers 2 c
calderon des livres mauriste
deux pays lors
qu'est ce qu'ils auront six value est
belle lui aussi avions de chasse
incroyable athlétiquement
pas mal sur le cut qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait dire d'autres sont lüthi petit
peu pas dribbler s'est rencontré dans le
cut
derrière c'est la vérité
j'adore kendalc'h
éviter couvert avec manu au lycée l'an
dernier il joue avec kennedy chandler le
genre de tennessee dit dans un programme
qui est très très bon qu'est un
programme pendant mon temps aux
etats-unis' analyse christine c'est dans
le kansas de mémoire et j'avais vu j'ai
dit wang run c'est noté haroun gordon
aaron garden of god parce que trois
cadres la tête auxerre qui monte sur des
à monté sur ressorts des flashs de peut
faire des passes et en fait je trouve
qu'elle faisait le meilleur contexte il
à baylor il joue trois quatre jours il
joue avec des efforts jour à côté
bolender lui demande de finir les
actions on lui demande de de faire des
passes on lui demande de défendre sur
plusieurs types de profil avec des
protecteurs de cercle derrière qui sont
chers à a eu et avec des bons défenseurs
sur les postes extérieurs donc il est le
contexte est parfait pour qu'il soit mis
en avant et je pense que le contexte de
leurs prêts pour masquer ses problèmes
encore qui sont bas je trouve que il
peut pas trop dribbler le tir à trois
points où il est à 50% mais il en prend
moins d'un par match donc pour moi c'est
par twitter voilà encore un shooter mais
voilà tu achètes un athlète à c'est un
mec aux ailes donc c'est très rare et
c'est très important pour les leviers
donc voilà je parle peut-être pas le
plus grand fan mais je comprends que les
gens aiment beaucoup canal bois
courbé leur jeu même pièce dessus toute
façon qu'il espère coller comme diabète
je suis un chant d'amour avec cette fac
donc sur surtout sur ce qu'ils
produisent puis eu plusieurs gens venus
de la banque jamais été déçu
et très jeunes aussi d'asie hugues
herbrecht ampère ok voilà ont fait le
reste est bon on a là un trio qui mars
kendall
24 médecins moi ce dont le tir de
gimmicks trois joueurs et lui c'est le
dernier que je mets le alors wimax est
fou comme le dial comme le dialogue ça
monte très haut
capable de switcher sur plusieurs postes
même s'il ya encore un petit peu de
difficulté latéral comme sur les
extérieurs j'ai pas non plus inventé un
stoppeur 1,5 ce serait pas vrai et des
fois ya encore un manque de lucidité
défensive puisqu'il est monté sur des
ressorts donc ils aiment bien sauté et
ça peut encore faire des erreurs par
contre je n'achète le dribble g7 les
dribbles et c'est sûrement ce qui fait
que alan la plus bas que mois plus tôt
peut-être fin de loterie et quoi je les
ai aussi haussé que je pense que c'est
un joueur qui peut
sur un renversement partir dès demain
j'ai vu beaucoup de finesse près du
panier ça je retiens mtein incroyable
qu'il absente très bien le contact il
reste en l'air et il change sa direction
dans les airs capable de changer de
mains dans les airs aussi
j'ai vu un joueur qui peut varier son
rythme donc il est en contact donc c'est
à dire qui peut ralentir et réaccélérer
donc voilà après il y avait toujours
cette sur deux contextes bel air est une
très grosse équipe classée 2 0,1
actuellement n 6 mai avec de grosses
ambitions tu as des joueurs veut
expérimenter donc t'es pas forcément là
pour développer un jeune comme peut le
faire même fils avec betc turenne et lui
il est un peu noyé la dont dix aces à
gonzaga aussi peut-être que le jour est
à poney dans le contexte est dans une
équipe moins bon aurait plus de
responsabilités donc voilà pour le tir
et j'ai envie d'y croire parce que le mi
distance me plaît parce que le lancer
franc il ya des progrès et que le volume
de tirs à trois points augmente au fur
et à mesure de la saison début de saison
n'en prenaient pas du tout il a refusé à
l'image de jérémy soran hélas de plus en
plus ils les prélats le droit et ça
commence à devenir de plus en plus
l'idée de plus en plus efficaces donc
voilà j'ai fait tout ça et c'est pour ça
que je les en cinquième position
l ex souhaité tempérer
en fait moi gelé depuis que je t'ai
envoyé à l'issue les ringards né et je
les fais glisser dans mon tir 3 buts 1
mondiale
[Musique]
parce que sinon déjà tout le monde
serait d'accord
et et non et je trouve qu'en fait il va
pas voir dans mon tiers 2 j'ai besoin
d'un mec qui peut être deuxième option
une troisième option
peut-être que ça sera le cas mais mais
en fait il est trop loin et je trouve
qu'ils profitent trop du contexte unis
disaient de dribbler dès demain mais en
fait il quand il compte y reçoit la
balle il a un mec qui arrive qu'ils
avaient un klose out de 4 mètres à faire
moi aussi je peux partir en 8es demandes
gracieuses
après je vais pas je vais pas jouer mais
si tu peux rendre des deux mains
s'affairent président ribeton équipe le
bain
ça dépend celle des pentes et hardy et
elle marche pas là dessus
mais mais ouais non je trouve qu'ils
profitent beaucoup du contexte d'alors
qui est une équipe extraordinaire qui
est peut-être la meilleure acquis du
pays
[Musique]
je suis d'accord avec tout ce qui a été
dit sur le
puissance corporelle dégager le fait
merde regard d'un mec jouer face à des
gamins et effectivement la comparaison
le cac rencontre avec gordon j ai même
pas pensé mais elle paraît évidente et
juste vu que j'achète pas le tir et que
je suis pas sûr qu'il puisse aller en
dribble comme je disais avec une des
trois cercles seulement
pour l'instant je vais le garder dans un
tir croisé où il sera un rôle player
plus plus plus et
basse pression tu dis allah n'est
sûrement pas d'accord avec tout ça l'est
dans le tir de mai bâtir deux
un joueur je sais pour en avoir déjà
parlé avec alan qu'on a du mal à classer
et que certains je sais j'ai vu sur
twitter qui n'ont très très haut c'est
dur n le pivot de memphis
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ce
joueur là monsieur comment vous arrivez
à l'estimé est ce qu'il a vu car est
caractéristique de pivot moderne ou pas
est ce que vous l'avez dans votre tiers
de 3 ou plus loin dites moi tout bien
les bernabeu c'est à dire commencé en
disant qu'il est 3,5 chez aspen
et top 10 si athlétique
soit entre 5 8 10 nous sommes tous les
records et qui les replace fait aussi
devait être dans la prochaine cohorte
est en fait il a réussi à se reclasser
il est de décembre ou de novembre 2003
et traiterait 18,9 en 2003 pour être
précis et il ya déjà un article qu'elle
en a fait chaud genre du rennais
l'estimation des pivots tu peux essayer
de mettre dans l'est dans le four
youtube en même temps pour pour que les
gens qui s'accompagnait lui aux jo les
deux textes
ne s'attaquait très épineuse roma tu
l'as vu toi jane un petit peu
[Musique]
c'est pas c'est pas nécessairement j'ai
un regard un peu trop peu européen mais
c'est pas nécessairement le genre de
joueur que j'affectionne
particulièrement
c'est un joueur de peinture et
d'au-dessus à ce sujet là ça le même si
c'est très pénible à regarder pour les
lieux
c'est absolument horrible espèce de
camouflage
[Musique]
portant dispersa moufles et dans le pti
a lieu une camouflé au milieu des au
milieu des histoires un peu suspecte de
recrutement et compagnie il ya plein de
choses
donc je vois de peinture joueurs
verticale comme tous les joueurs en plus
verticaux c'est un petit peu ça manque
un peu de puissance alors pas d'exploser
les puissants sur le bas du camp ce qui
va être lui tout seul c'est pas
forcément trop ça trop sa sauce par
contre beaucoup de mobilité alors faut
savoir qui joue dans huit mètres carrés
inter qu' il va jouer dans
dans la peinture mais vraiment dans la
zone basse de la peinture par contre
tout ce qui va passer un mètre cinquante
à deux mètres autour de lui il prend
émettant cirque a vraiment bien ce qu'il
fait est assez limité même s'il sait
faire des choses un peu un peu léman
terre dans le sens où il est capable de
tourner sur ses épaules de chercher d ou
des choses comme ça mais voilà ça manque
de puissance en bas et c'est c'est
plutôt sur le sol turc on va le chercher
défensivement il fait des choix parfois
un peu baroque
lille et lens sur les clausade que tu
l'as aventure un peu loin par contre il
ya du rebond il ya la protection du
certain il va être pendant 2-3 conforme
à deux je pense il n'est pas forcément
trop à la faute même si ccc borderline
et puis le principal défaut jeudi
ça reste quand même qu'il a énormément
les bras en basse qui pourront alors on
pose un peu problème mais je suis pas
surpris de le voir je suis pas surpris
de le voir
potentiellement loterie parce que
sans comparer ce qui n'est pas
comparable mais des profils comme ça
j'ai oublié son nom avait un navet un
joueur comme ça bon
dès lors est allé moi voilà c'est ça
c'est des procédés profil un peu pareil
des joueurs verticaux des joueurs plutôt
de deux alley hoop de transition de
choses comme ça des mecs qui vont
profiter des driver et la qualité de
passes des autres pour aller
éventuellement où vous cherchez des
balles au dessus du cercle ou aller sur
des sur des poutres bach schubert bref
des joueurs comme ça sur ses profits là
il y en a toujours besoin dans des dents
dans des équipes nba toujours et puis
bon bah malgré tout ça va ça va vite
voyez michelle robinson aussi pareil
soit lassé des profils un petit peu
comme ça ce que nous dit
non ils disent voilà c'est ça donc c'est
merci merci pour la précision également
je pensais pas je pensais pas messieurs
robinson voilà ça c'est un profil un peu
comme ça qui est pas inintéressant après
l'autre icc un peu survendu mais sur pas
il faut avoir ce qui est autour il faut
voir ce qu'il ya comme profondeur sur la
sur l art à ce poste-là est
le seul souci c'est que ben attia léon
s'effronder ma tâche et c'est pas simple
je pense que là il ya un vrai chantier
de ce côté là bas
les défenseurs de duren met très souvent
avant sa qualité de passe ont justifié
justement le fait qu'ils doivent
beaucoup
brennan c'est vrai j'ai été blacklisté
pendant des années comme celui qui dit
détester l'intérieur c'est vrai c'est
vrai parce que comme l'a dit et a
toujours besoin mais si on me dit
michelle robinson ben oui d'accord mais
je peux draft pas très haut parce que je
pense que je peux trouver plus bas c'est
ça la question autour de du rennais et
se poster mais je trouve que pourquoi je
léger fin du tiers deux donc c'est un
mec que je referai en loterie
franchement je le draff très fins de
loterie entre 10 et 14 je le prends
parce que je trouve que déjà il a ce
potentiel de protecteur de cercle et de
capacités vraiment être très bon
défensivement et je trouve qu'à la passe
il est capable de faire des choses
st certes tu malgré je mets des choses
que je trouve qu'ils rendent un peu la
tac qui c'est pas un mec c'est pas un
vol stoppeur sera qu'un qui qui fait un
peu d'équipés qui qui n'est pas capable
de faire fonctionner une attaque quand
il a la balle alors il est pas très bien
mise en avant par memphis qui n'a pas de
meneur en face m'en dire le projet de
memphis c'est de développer le money
beit sur deux ans je peux le comprendre
et je suis arrivé à faire drafté money
boys auront réussi cependant c'est pas
la meilleure chose pour mettre en avant
ton intérieur qui d'abord un poseur
d'écran et un mec qui finisse comme ça
donc il n'a pas il est pas mis souvent
dans des super bonne situation mais je
trouve que les gens je regarde je
regarde je regarde des images en même
temps j'en reviens après bastien romain
va regarder alabama première mi-temps
cela je suis mr finale j'étais inquiète
moi j'ai téléchargé c'est tout et peut
désormais se regarde un petit peu là je
trouve que volaille ldc
vas-y alex un résident
j'ai pu les stats mais je trouve quoi il
est capable de faire des renversements
il est capable de passer un peu
waouh comme disait mathias et des passes
à une main super fort c'est pas très
fluide c'est pas mais je trouve que à 18
ans être à 10 % de passes décisives pour
un poste 500 gardes plaît bah c'est pas
affreux et je pense qu'il peut être un
passeur
en passeur solide pour à l'intérieur et
c'est pas le cas de beaucoup d'intérieur
oui ils en payent ils en perdent
beaucoup apprécié tout en l'aimant banc
à chaque fois ces volets ballon parce
que c'est moi elles sont en bas et quand
il reprend le rebond et redescend
comique natchaba des redescend et
systématiquement elle tape la balle dans
la main il la perd comme un enfant quoi
je suis en train de regarder les images
là je peux faire ce que tu dit alan sur
un truc tout ça doit le fait qu'ils les
aiment en bas il a même problème en
défense implantation donc ça c'est ça
c'est quelque chose qui est voilà son
son pourcentage de passes en fait
tu peux le pondérer d'une façon très
simple il a très peu la balle en fait
globalement si tu regardes alors attends
je me remets sur les dix mille fenêtres
d'ouvertes qu'en même temps
il est il et j'ai pas la moyenne il est
à 63 tirs 10 matches il va prendre six
tirs par match
à 70 % quasiment
donc c'est à dire que potentiellement tu
as une vraie efficacité dans ce qui fait
hyper pas énormément il yad'autres du
ring 3 balles perdues dire que et ans et
qui jouent peu de possession qui pose
que la balle au sol navy tellement il a
peut perdre la balle
par contre tu vois dans le jeu les
attraper sont quand même tous
il sait pas propre il n'y a pas de bonis
contrôle du tout si l'arc dès qu'il a la
balle dans les mains globalement s'il ya
quelque chose à en faire a pour traiter
plusieurs informations ont du sang qui a
comme un conflit dans la gestion du
ballon complètement il ya pour monde
pour moi alors dans les faits oui il
arrive à mettre la balle où il veut mais
bon pas ce bon passeur je sais pas et le
potentiel de bons passeurs
il a ce potentiel est moi je pense
qu'ils les voient là je pense que
les voix et c'est déjà bien
mais n'est en fait je suis pas sûr qu'il
ait des morts où il exécute pas c'est
bien il bosse pas la balle au sol pour
rien ce qui est déjà énorme sincèrement
mais là je le voyais sur les prises à
deux il prend le temps il prend le temps
de lire mais ou auto temps il a
identifié la situation mais la réponse
technique par contre elle et elle est
souvent dégueulasse parce que y'a pas
d'habitude de désaxés et puis surtout à
la salle étaient les mains après
derrière la contre contrôle et michalek
trouve un backdoor sur la situation du
costaud voilà il ya des choses
intéressantes il ya pas tout acheter non
plus un mais c'est ça reste
à tout et agir parce je pense que tout
est à faire sur ce suivi mais ils
n'auront été ouverts mais déjà il pose
pas la balle au sol
la comparaison du chat un passeur alain
robin williams est ce que c'est pas un
peu les mêmes jour de flash on pouvait
voir de robin williams à
cnn
déjà
tu me rappelles que trop de
points
c'est peu mais je sais que il allait
jouer latéralement
ouais mais le morphotype ou plus et il
ya un contexte je pense qu'il faut
rappeler même fils on est là pour vendre
des joueurs on est là pour faire de la
vitrine car nous n'exposons dit regarder
les beaux
n'est pas là pour gagner vraiment des
matches
tous les mecs qui passent par memphis
reste qu'un an ou finissent par quitter
et soient cédés prospectifs sont achetés
très vite au premier tour soit il
disparaît totalement et on n'entend plus
parler de l'an dernier à moussa cissé
bien qu'ils vont un peu similaire très
athlétique cas du transfert après les
désastreuses il ya deux ans où il a
réussi avant de préciser cette choix et
wiseman qui est partie comme pas inquiet
a réparti en deux et d'autre mais qui
sont ils ont dû transférer que c'est
donc c'est un contexte très bizarre même
pis je pense qu'il faut rappeler oui bon
sens qui intéressait donc j'allais bien
des raisons mais
on aimerait que dans le jeu
moi tu voies gênant pour le pour le
short de leicester qui donnait ces
célébrations de guitare à trois points
plutôt que pour le basket c'est en fait
même temps ça va de soi tu peux pas bien
joué avec autant de jeunes joueurs
avec des ensembles il ya un minimum je
trouve bien mais qu'est ce qui te fait
quoi tennistique quelqu'un qui fait quoi
depuis dix ans passés le même modèle ils
jouent mal sauf cette année avait un peu
mieux parce qu'ils ont créé des
supplices super senior voilà projet de
s'aimer c'est intéressant sur un miracle
0,20 tout début d'émission conséquent
celle du niveau des joueurs qui arrivent
aussi à la pandémie il ya ça il ya aussi
fait que la pandémie elle a permis en
fait pour le joueur senior de 6 5e année
ya des supers moments une fillette au
cas des égards de niveaux énormes et
d'espérer un énorme entre des joueurs
qui viennent d'arriver et qu'on
quasiment pas joué leur dernière année
de high school et des joueurs qui sont
dans leur cinquième année d'un gars john
culberson vierge il était midi johnnie
carson il a 24 ans fleurs
là son cabinet d'experts comptables il
est bien
sûr trop vite c'est tourner aux siens
c'est normal qu'ils dominent
complètement du rennes pour je l'avais
vu cet été je m'étais intéressé à ce
qu'était le fameux y blg
c'est carrément quasiment faut un bac +7
pour comprendre comment sont formés les
équipes et tout ça il a été mvp il a
gagné des duels avec son équipe et c'est
le all-star des lycées césar
ayew d'été ou un truc comme ça et en
gros il joue avec un autre intérieur de
2 10 je trouve ça un peu bizarre et il
faisait beaucoup de protection de cèpes
secondaire n'était qu'un autre mais le
mec à qui les thèmes qui faisait de dix
tirs à trois points était un mec qui
ampute yens soit et lui il agissait
beaucoup en deuxième rideau n'était pas
vraiment le langres défensive et en
attaque on l'a vu prendre un peu de
distance alors le geste sais pas c'est
vraiment très très mais on l'a vu
prendre mes distances donc je me dis il
y en a peut-être un peu pris
jeu il a que 10 vient d'avoir 18 ans
enfin de loterie dalila profil
athlétique jeux peuvent je peux me
laisser tenter maintenant j'y crois très
fort par exemple ouais ils l'adorent et
nador qu'est-ce que voilà il a toujours
dit là et c'est un genre qui a toujours
ultra dominés chez les jeunes et c'est
normal il a un physique
c'est les bras qu'il à la musculature
pour son âge il avait déjà à 16 ans il
sur dominé tout le temps il a peut-être
ça qui l'a peut-être pas appris voilà le
poster alors j'appelle plus léché
offensivement parce que voilà tu dis
mettait la balle en finisseur proche du
cercle qui démarre et où tout est
pourtant manuel aime les basketteurs
normalement
les joueurs dont on parlait tout à
l'heure c'est laisser les mecs qui font
de notre carrière en nba
c'est pas mal moi je des profils comme
ça toute façon dans le jeu il en faut un
an et demi et il en faut et c'est des
joueurs qui peuvent s'adapter donc c'est
pas à laquelle je ne pense pas après
derrière les socios je dors tu sais
qu'elle va je lui donne un jeu de sept
millions c'est quoi c'est quoi sa salle
et on va dire 6 14 comme joueur
et encore tu vas en fait nous pour moi
sa dette cela dépendra énormément
peut-être plus que pour d'autres deux
évaluations psychologiques
c'est un joueur qui a tellement de
travail à faire que s'il ya juste des
petites questions sur son éthique sur la
manière dont
il va prendre du retard dans le
développement
peut-être peut-être un jour tu peux
passer à côté de son contrat rookie
facilement s'il travaille pas bien donc
donc pour moi ça va être encore plus
important pour les joueurs et c'est pour
ça que j'ai que dans un tiers 3 parce
que pour moi c'est un bois raconte texte
un jour
je suis d'accord c'est un joueur à
contexte suppose qu'ils considéraient
qu'ils les jeunes qu'il a du temps et
c'est peut-être avec cette là quelqu'un
qui vous bouffe elhadji aussi un petit
peu au départ et insidieux
que toi alex sur la mentalité mais c'est
vrai qu'ils font ne voit pas toujours
faire les efforts diane dufresne est
cette fois complètement perdus sur des
situations assez c'est dan fisher voilà
les moments des lettons sont vraiment
perdu elle revient ministre sur le banc
des maîtres du jeu sans doute mais
j'avais pris j'avais noté ça tout à
l'heure sur qui également j'avais déjà
sur un autre joueur s'est essayée sur
elle sur ben kargbo
le mec sait pas qui sait pas qui
comprend qui comprend pas défensivement
mais banque héros je voyais pour moi il
ya un manque de discipline mais surtout
un manque de vécu parce que d'identifier
les situations c'est par l'entraînement
qu'on fait c'est dans le travail
collectif hélas ces mecs là il certains
sont entraînés réellement 55 pendant
pendant quasiment un an à cet âge là
c'est dramatique
derek avec des joueurs déjà qu'avec des
joueurs expérimentés quand on va
récupérer parfois après cinq semaines de
break l'été on repart de zéro et on
cravache mais on a des idées des joueurs
qui ont déjà du vécu là sur des jeunes
joueurs comme ça il ya tout à construire
mais si tu regardes c'est pour ça que je
parle est dédié griffin en termes si
angie alors je le trouve vraiment très
impressionnant sur la compréhension en
fait les pour moi là où ça se voit le
plus c'est quand c'est le bordel c'est à
dire que quand c'est pas organisé hier
bon finalement il ya une perte de balle
tout de suite et c est qu il faut
retrouver quelqu'un il faut faire le bon
choix tout de suite il faut avoir
l'instinct pour
prendre la bonne décision collective et
écrit-il à châteauroux grain est en
avance clairement
effectivement
ne pas pas de danse
actifs gagnent des joueurs de
65,8 les par le papa de jack griffin
s'est adressé fils d'ancien joueur des
bulls c'est l'assistant à toronto et en
fait aidé j'ai passé l'année dernière
attends pas avec les oies avec les
raptors pendant un an pour se rééduquer
un peu peut-être que ça a été super tu
peux banner le mec dans le champ lucius
vite fait on en a on a un petit un petit
buzz russe je sais pas trop quoi là
qu'il faut bannir rapidement par des
noirs donc les gens qui sont sur le lien
est face au petit problème désoler
mais tellement tellement influent qu'on
est comme quand on est attaqué par les
russes
c'est là que je suis sur le chat y avait
quelques questions on va prendre ce type
de question il ya combat continuera à
aller sur le tiers de
une question de perrigny sur nicolas
iodice que c'est un autre qui disent qu
ils rentrent dedans se tient en dehors
possiblement c'est questionable non pas
du tout avec ce jeu là c'est moi je
l'espère trois mois tiens moi aussi et
je dois le revoir vous que les derniers
matches que j'ai vus d'être dupé eu dès
16 ans et ça ne m'avait pas trop j'avais
revu
avancé avant aventure juste avant noël
et parce que j'avais résidents manque de
l'ec adriatique tout simplement donc
cette fois des problèmes envoyés et
ouais le tir est vraiment une qualité
incroyable son utilisation défensive me
frustre énormément en fait on le fait
défendre sur les petit meneur américain
des équipes brigue adriatique il se fait
torpiller le pauvre parce qu'il n'a pas
de mobilité tout ça parce qu'il ya plus
de choses à faire avec lui mais voilà il
ya papa il n'a pas le potentiel pour
qu'on lui donne la ballerine viennent
simplement on apprenne quelles tels que
le modèle défensif j'avais de cap du
sénat comme ça aussi ils se sont dit ça
a fonctionné avec des miettes il ya
peut-être chacune vous aviez aussi le
foot est sur les meneurs c'est vrai
c'est un peu une réalité défensive et
c'est un super d'attention m bia
maintenant aptes à l'efb intérêts encore
des questions en composant
mais au moment de ses draps tout les
gens disaient ah je sais pas je vous
rejoins sur tout mais néophyte voilà
c'est fait et c'est peut-être que du
coup ses répétitions là le jour des
mineurs trop rapides pour lui vont
l'aider aussi d'autres cas dans la
chaussure du pick n pop / de la capacité
à faire un choix sur un renversement il
peut il est pétri de talent là dessus
mais kalex a choisi son camp ça nous les
temps changent tout le temps mais c'est
vrais hackers bête n'est apparemment
c'est juste moi je moi je me suis arrêté
sur un vieux à celles exprimées vitrine
at elle encore une fois c'est des
équipes qui vont des prospects des
prospects et qui sont là
pour vendre en nba derrière mais ils
gagnent quelques matchs quand même ils
gagnent quelques matchs dans la ligue 1
bezos plus simonovic cédant protège
avec crazy la star qui demandait si le
doublé son était un premier tour où
appareil c'est comme vue bien de dire
ces fermes à talant
encore plus la ligne aile il en trouvera
alors et s'en fait pas partie du
programme
ciellement mais ils ont le nectar ce
programme qui met en avant en fait des
jeunes joueurs locaux et internationaux
pas mal d'internationaux sont allés
s'exiler là bas particulièrement cette
année
besson est de loin celui qui s'en sort
le mieux
de très très loin donc c'est ça ça ça
parle pour lui c'est à dire que ça tape
ça veut dire qu'il est prend du plaisir
il a
[Musique]
tout ce dont on se doutait déjà pour
être enfin trois autres meilleurs scores
de pro b il faut pas être à une vie
maintenant
pour moi sur ce que j'ai vu il n'a rien
montré de plus que l'année dernière
quasiment c'est à dire je peut scorer je
peux jouer un pick and roll
occasionnellement jeu peut scorer pardon
avec un astérisque c'est-à-dire compte
des athlètes de niveau annuel nba ces
mêmes balles à jay leach port et
est en fait défensivement il nous faut
retrait limité de sueur ça qu'on
l'attend et on en parlait avec avec son
ancien dans le canard 1
2 3 et avec jc pratique c'est là aussi
un parent guillet faut quand même savoir
des ford en y était mais qu'ils sont
nuls en laissant ce qu'en dit quoi
après je sais que j avais il disait
aussi que parent qui comprenait des
forces il y avait des rédactions de et
certainement de défense au collectif qui
était bien
là
bas
un groupe et les pedigrees basket elle
aussi
est ce que il ya des cas qui démontre on
a parlé de john allan davis dans le
tiers 2
non on n'a pas parlé d'une vingtaine
davis d'ailleurs le quart d'heure on l'a
à peine on l'a commencée
vu qu'il nous reste pas longtemps une
once un quart d'heure je vais vous
laisser choisir le joueur dont vous
voulez parler absolument que vous rendez
non mais que vous avez plus haut que la
moyenne
mais tu as vu mon board moi j'ai que ça
développe plus que jamais je fais
n'importe quoi
donc mais quel con pas été évoquée
à la ddt je sais pas moi je pense que ne
pas être de taille taille bonnie tout à
tahiti
j'aurais pu parler d'héritage estime
sofia
taiwo sérieuse laitière deux beaucoup de
gens là un peu plus bas à s'éloigner
benchikhi je crois en une meilleure
utilisation n'diaye mais j'ai envie de
parler de moussa diabaté ouais moussa
diabaté on peut justement l'escalier il
ya un si grand écart entre moussa
diabaté indiennes et du nord chez moi
non complètement quoi il y en a pas oui
c'est pour çà ses mots ses mots vibre
encore toi tu dis s'il n'était pas dans
même tiers et des fois je me réveille
nous le dise en rivière j'adore moussa
diabaté
j'avais adoré ce que j'avais vu je crois
que c'était en grèce fiba u18 en 2019 à
img c'était aussi très bien et là je
vois un profil défensif plus plus
capable de toujours actif toujours dans
les compréhensions je vois un joueur
capable de passer aussi le tir je sais
pas si j'achète voilà pris quelques uns
trois points c'est la grande question
il joue aussi avec interdit kynsna côte
est qui voilà c'est un très bon joueur
et une 6ème interne de spe singh mais
tout c'est très frustant à regarder il
commence à prendre les devants ouais
j'ai vu en prenant compte wince la ville
d'amilly d'un ami doute et voilà je
trouve j'adore l'activité j'adore le
potentiel j'adore la capote et j'adore
le potentiel de paris en fait pour qu'un
intérieur qui est pas générationnel sont
un peu plus haut que la moyenne chez moi
fous qu'ils puissent passer conquis
complices et un peu gêné un peu attaque
avec lui c'est à dire faire du dribble
ndog c'est à dire donner la balle je me
mets alors que c'est horrible je sais
pas le faire mais qui sincèrement
on regarde qui serait la pire des looks
quoi vous avez la nuit qu'ils soient qui
se fait ailleurs égales fallen ces
incapables de jeu pas de bras de fer
renversement sur short rôle qu'ils
soient capables de renverser la bad sur
un post up voilà et c'est ça par contre
je pense que diabaté peut le faire et
j'adore le moteur j'adore l'énergie et
l'eau me et donc
motricité
je dois noter que l année la première
personne que j'ai entendu parler d'eux
de diabaté entre 20 et je trouve que
c'est assez fou parce que ça n'est pas
vrai du tout évident quand on voit la
commune défensif ou petrova michigan
qu'un système pas facile à prendre
hugues est ce que tu as un joueur dont
on n'a pas parlé que tu veux devrait
absolument mentionner allez je vais
faire un choix entre deux jets palais je
vais prendre sur ses promenades et
rayonne cibone terrebonne qui est un
meneur et ce à deux mètres 0 1 qui joue
du côté de north carolina state and
systems nos clients wolf pack office ici
à aimer d'or c'est un mec y tient
haendel incroyable qui sur un premier
pari pécs possible sur les demain qui
peut aller au panier qui n'ai jamais
arrêté soit tu le laisses passer soit tu
fais faute soit ira tout seul
qui défendent pas du tout cas une
latéralité très moyenne pour être
honnête avec avec vous donc je pense que
en nba c'est un il jouera il jouera 3,4
au niveau du tir il ya très peu de tirs
ça commence de plus en plus moi j'aime
bien les joueurs qui qui progresse au
fur et à mesure et les sophomores cette
année
donc voilà c'est un regard des dérives
lebron il est à 80 ouais il prend 82 %
de ces tirs près du banni 60% de
réussite de ces tirs la et plus d'une
fois sur deux lorsqu'il va au cirque
liens dans ces francs donc je les enlève
pas loin de mon top 10
le prix des 1027 non non non il y va
cette année il ira cet accroissement au
vrai ça dépendra de son tournoi et de
conférences en fait si m6 tétouan sans
personne n'en parle mais moi j'avoue je
vous ai dit j'ai pas regardé les modes
donc je sais pas si on en parle dans les
mots coupat je pense que non parce que
quand j'en parle les gens me disent
qu'ils étaient de mon chat qui essaient
de me censurer actuellement deux
sculpteurs bonjour la caméra et
messi côté jour si j'ai pas les stades
comme ça me chante il vers 18 points ont
peu près un tel n donne une telle
fluidité intel explosivité je peux pas
le laisser passer loterie mencia
plaintes des fois c'est très brut très
très brut d'ailleurs hier brawn dans le
nom de famille est pas pour rien
mais voilà allez voir des régions dites
moi ce que vous en pensez et acheter le
acheté le fonds mais regarder le match
contre nebraska qui vend quatre
prolongations si vous avez du temps à
perdre mais tout
[Musique]
est très haute il n'a pas parlé de pas
de baldwin aussi
personnellement je vais quand même dans
toute l'asie
moi j'ai pas du tout
un autre vivant tous les bals qui alex
du coup je voulais parler à l'est nous
sommes maintenant en plus il devrait y
avoir
demain sur notre site
c'est un joueur qui joue à notre dame
le sauveur qui ont chaussé leurs pions
voix d'isabelle bling bling ou est ce
lycée d'un freshman je vais vérifier ça
parce que cette année jsp n'a pas
actualisé mais je crois que c'est un
vrai fraîche pas
[Musique]
de la chance sur robert gates
les couettes lit donc il est grand pour
un garde il fait c'est un de moins de
deux mètres
il est rapide
il shoote bien il est long il a une
grosse activité des mains que ce soit
aux principes mais surtout défensive
mais je trouvais intéressant dans son
activité et son activité des mains et sa
discipline aussi
il peut se créer sentir hills le crès
assez facilement d'ailleurs à mi
distance pour l'instant et finit pas
très bien près du panier parce qu il a
encore besoin de
d'accepter le contact mieux que ça mais
il y va simplement juste en serait il le
soutient ce propos je pense que c'est
quelque chose qu'il peut se régler parce
qu'il est parlante et hyper fin il a des
épaules il devrait pouvoir accepter en
en rajoutant un autre poids et
et en fait ça me paraît assez évident
qu'un meneur grand parce que moi je ne
savais pas trop les jambes trop petit on
va là nous pas des gens
est un meneur de cette taille est
capable de m'ont dit souvent shooter
passes et dribbles et et qu'
il ya déjà de la discipline qui joue
dans une taille mais jobs
qui a la confiance de mike breen qui est
un des coaches qui a le plus de
l'exigence sur le système offensif
de sa conférence est donnée de l'acier
en général je trouve
c'est très intéressant et je pense qui
peut selon moi il a un niveau de l'autre
je pense je pense qu'il peut être un
joueur
le deuxième porteur de balle d'une bonne
idée à terre et festive très tranchant
ouais il va en fait il a très vite il
fait des différences et si l'on regarde
aussi ça qui parvient à provoquer des
fautes qui parvient à inscrire de
l'espace et négoce lice créé des espaces
y perd facilement mais il n'a pas
forcément besoin d'un écran pour centrer
je pense que derrière kennedy chandler
très rapide en spéciale de joueurs qui
se connaissent pas ce dernier
roman est ce qu'il ya un joueur que tu
as vu kit a particulièrement plu
dont 13 très honnêtement j'ai été plus
pris par la bcl et par le championnat de
france que que par la haine pied je vais
me mettre un petit à petit la je suis
allé sur les semaines qui viennent mais
je ne sert absolument à rien là-dedans
débat est ce qu'il a vu le pivot de
belles europa
moi j'ai pas riche mais c'est drôle
quand même
on a des questions landais sont déjà
parlé
des joueurs italiens en haut de nos deux
bords de voile à 0 0 qui est à double
dames nationalité des soldats peut-être
aussi mais je n'ai pas revu cette année
aussi vous non leur nombre est mort
c'est le seul
jeu qu'on a ratées doute question vous
sentez bien et pour revenir sur john
allan davis la question de l'ouest
il ya quatre ans chez rapidement gg je
n'ai pas assez vu pouvoir donner un avis
particulier mais c'est un joueur qui en
tout cas une grosse progression
et du coup c'est toujours intéressant de
voir des joueurs comme ça qui dès leur
saison sophomore domine on dit et ça
veut dire que y'a quelque chose et qu'on
fait de l'atteinte des dix ans fait
partie
des thèmes de société aussi cette
activité était aussi oui il ya là nous
vous l'avez vu ouali est
un super joueur de college je sais pas
ce qu'ils m'apportent de plus ou de
spécial pour la nba donc drafté mais
défend un très bon joueur bon nombre de
rotations ça sera un bon jour de
rotation moi je le trouve trop lent
et
le couperet
ça dégage
comme je trouve le long et que je le
vois pas du tout cas passer de créer
quoi que ce soit bah lendemain il va
descendre je les ai vus j'ai vu certains
ont parlé pour de la loterie que c'était
à moi j'ai eu beau linge comme des
joueurs qui peuvent créer de l'attaquant
au tri
et je crois pas que j'attendais l'iss
puissent le faire et donc du coup est ce
qu'il peut faire autre chose peut-être
est-ce qu il le fait aussi bien que des
spécialistes je pense pas donc je vais
peut-être avoir du temps de premier tour
pour l'instant
il ya paul qu'ils montrent qu'ils aient
le plus au plafond chet
voilà de nous tous direct ces moines y
avait trois mètres
avec les valides fort
d'un procès jack griffin honnêtement
pour moi aussi les genoux le laissent
tranquille c'est écrit film
honnête qui a dont jouit parce que
le coup comme vous voyez là il a vu
qu'il y avait à manger juste à côté
regardez moi ces jeux de prédateurs ont
tiré un prospecteur bien fraîche man il
est comme son père et leur nom excuse
moi
les fils ou chet
il ya la question impressions sur
semaine ging ouais
je les ai malheureusement je n'ai pas vu
de match de nba 2000 mètres moi je
m'entends les mutins avaient aussi ouais
ça se passe pas faim il convainc peu
convainc peu dans la création et cetera
pasquet pas trop de progrès donc je suis
assez inquiet en fait 2 j je sais pas tu
nous avais dit que c'est un projet sur
deux ans
goûter des gens qui connaissent leur
métier
c'est effectivement un projet sur deux
ans mais ça peut pas d'un projet à court
terme est toutefois sombre oui oui c'est
ça mais mais en fait
notre foi chez plus où j'ai vu ça qui
demandait sur le sur twitter
sur les réponses sur envergure faisait
quand même top en externe en fait il a
des problèmes au moment où on peut
presque pas de juger parce qu'il vivait
quasiment
il est négative pour son équipe c'est
dur ce que je dis mais mais ça veut pas
dire que ça va pas changer mais pour
l'instant c'est d'un boulet continuer
sur le terrain pour son équipe y'a pas
de n'est pas notre manière de formuler
et voilà ces premiers contexte pro qui
connaît je crois de mémoire il sort de
l'insep il change de continent il a 18
ans dans une équipe où en plus il ya un
autre prospects en négo besson qui est
vieira ils ont en plein parcours
différent les de quoi les deux parfois
il est vrai plus il opposait possible
donc je pense quand même après le talent
qu'on avait vu en fiba jeunes et d'où il
est là il la mort de l'autre ça c'est un
demi trois très très jeune amar est la
question c'est est ce qu'il va y aller
et il est dans le contrat en extase
comme l'a dit alex est ce que ça veut
dire que c'est un an ou deux ans je sais
pas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut pour
des récits c'est unique professionnels
ces normes c'est la normalité et c'était
un mec comme la meinau ball qui
je pense que la normalité c'est plus que
tu galères quoi dans ce genre de
situation à 18 ans ya aussi pour sa
poésie avec sherbrooke non juste il
n'est pas dans le
fumier après je dois y aller il et il
n'est pas dans le rôle
qui pourrait en bus n'est plus le mettre
en valeur c'est à dire que lui pour
l'instant le skill qu'il a par rapport à
d'autres à ce niveau là c'est sa
capacité de lire le jeu sur os sur
pick'n roll et sa voix et sa lecture de
jeu et son jeu de passe en fait il là il
abat le ballon parce que qui s'est pas
créé lui-même et c'est quoi une seconde
demande en premier un joueur ou
ça fonctionne pas et vous l'oeil des
plantes et dans le corner qui reçoit la
balle il n'arrive pas à faire la
différence je suis pas bien
c'est injouable c'est ça c'est un joueur
qui a besoin d'avoir la balle après je
n'en reviens scholes et à leur porte
graine encore une fois pour le cameroun
pour d'autres il est né en 2003 donc
cercla on parle d'un joueur qui vient
d'avoir 18 ans dans un contexte
oui les autres au bout du monde c'est
reparti avec ses parents mais quand même
avec la pression inhérente au contrat
qu'il a qui est quand même important
l'idée la draft et ainsi de suite pour
l'instant on fait que croiser ce avec
les infos qu'on assure sur la
personnalité surtout ça c'est
c'est pas surprenant et c'est encore une
fois des process qui prennent du temps
on peut pas arriver tout de suite il ya
que les joueurs bramont de très très
très haut standing up s'adapter et tout
de suite efficace quelque part la
normalité c'est parfois de déménager de
se planter et d'avoir un peu de mal et
devoirs du met du temps à s'adapter
instruite pour autant que le joueur ait
acheté à acheter aux orties autres c'est
juste à prendre du temps la laïque c'est
bien mais la réalité c'est ça
[Musique]
la clé de suite compris ce qu'on peut
avoir peut-être c'est qu'au début
effectivement la star prévu c'était lui
dans l'équipe il joue côté des new
zealand bricolo se situe pas de bêtises
l'équipe hugo besson était un peu moins
cotés et donc hugo besson aux débutants
les tout premiers va tout et pas du tout
et yang ou plus et que la tendance est
inverse totalement et qu'on finit par ne
plus parler de spedding et qu'on parle
beaucoup du goût mais elles sont et
c'est logique vous a laissé lui d'un
code pin code d'un côté papa papa un
jeune doit soir du centre fédéral qui
n'a jamais rien véhicule du milieu
professionnel la haute que ce qu'il a pu
voir à la télé et l'autre côté tu as you
go besson qui était à chalon mon espoir
est qu'ils devaient peut-être en train
avec les pros je sais pas j'étais pas
l'époque et l'an dernier je vois requis
et deux mineurs en pro b et et qui fait
qu'ils tapent dans une équipe de haut de
tableau ont prouvé une pas déjà qu'à
québec a déjà connu des choses aussi qui
a déjà connu l'exigence d'un coach
exigences des résultats et compagnie
n'ont pas que l'espagne n'est pas que
l'existence d'un coach en nationale une
sauf que la différence c'est que
l'équipe est protégé et les joueurs ont
le temps de développer à juste titre en
lien avec le centre fédéral en pro b la
réalité différente hugo est plus vieux
aussi a connu des choses le père a été
joueur l'oncle a été joueur le
grand-père avec les coaches si vite on
est sur des contexte totalement
différent donc là on compare on parle de
trucs qui pour moi sont
sociaux sont très éloignées la réalité
par contre c'est que ta fleur ville du
basket déménager s'adapter à l'étranger
c'est pas quelque chose de facile et que
ben encore une fois dès 8 ans etc ces
jeunes et cette eau il faut être capable
de te dire l truc aussi
normal que c'est normal que dieng soit
moins bon goût besson mais ça veut pas
dire que sa draft est derrière mais
vraiment ce que le produit sur le
terrain c'est normal qu'ils soient
membres ou
privés sont la balle dieng ne l'a pas la
quiétude que j'ai tu vois c'est que la
haine dit elle et je te rejoins sur tout
ce que tu dire mais la nba levant un
programme qui envoie en nba devant des
stars avant des affiches sont très bons
dans leur communication et on n'est plus
du tout jour du pass 4 jours du
marketing et que s'y tient confirme pas
cette année qui le met de côté et que le
joueur sans tarder dans un projet qui
marche et vous ferez quoi dans les faits
on est tous les maillons d'une chaîne
aujourd'hui moi je suis entraîneur de
basket mais je travaille pourquoi dans
la réalité pour des boîtes de paris
sportifs la réalité en bout de chaîne
césar dont car nous n'en ai jamais on a
beau rentrée délais quand on se lève
pour entraîner les jours le matin on
vend des pommes bonne volonté on dijon
c'est l'entrée des joueurs on va les
développer les aider les accompagner
machin qui s'est arrêtée mais dans les
faits comme de toute façon toutes les
ligues sportives au monde ont baissé le
pantalon ils sont de toute façon dû
façon votre achille et que les paris
sportifs qui est la seule chose qui va
générer de l'argent lui bosse pour des
paris sportifs donc bah oui quand tu es
joueur tu rentres dans une logique de
marketing et oui un moment ou un autre
ben oui la nbl ils sont bien sûr ce truc
là par contre contrairement à la ligue
de celle où la nbl ils ont un deal ils
exigeront des deals qui rapporte de
l'argent au club au niveau de la télé et
ainsi de suite donc oui certes ils sont
dans cette logique là mais par contre
ils ont les contreparties nous on allie
les avantages qu'ils les inconvénients
aujourd'hui on n'a plus à contenir des
avantages d'ailleurs pour d'autres
raisons donc quelque part il faut
accepter qu tu rentres dans cette
logique de deux sports au est un maillon
d'une chaîne - je me lève le matin pour
bosser pour betclic tant pis
y'a quoi qu'il ait moins d'un avis sur
max christie n'a pas pareil de christie
houston michigan a écouté
je devais faire un stream pour parler de
max christie et une coupure de courant
donc j'ai fait que le premier joueur tu
vois je pense qu'on relancera ce stream
l'âge leurs frais mais max christie oui
j'aime j'aime bien j'achète pas
forcément très très haut parce que trois
pas dans le dribble encore une fois je
pense que c'est un joueur qui arrive pas
un secret il n'est pas assez puissant
près du panier les longs et
défensivement ils encaissent pas du tout
bien le contact
c'est un shooteur normalement de très
haut volume il était réputé pour sa
sortie de high school hélas cette année
il ya 2 % de réussite je crois donc ça
rentre pas pour lui donc il a une
première année compliquée
ce qu'on n'a pas un petit peu d'ailleurs
entre les 2 2 michigan à michigan state
les mêmes journaux difficultés des
joailliers estampillé shooter qui ont eu
du mal à exister et c'est
juste avait plus un porteur de balle
dans la tête ou la puce juin au parcours
précédents que moi mais c'était
important de balle que maxime pour être
un shooter un chanteur de system has
athlétique voilà c'est endemol mais
de facto camp parce que c'était le
meilleur joueur et parce que mais pour
moi c'est plus un joueur de french and
que les booster et voit les deux les
deux ans après voilà tu arrives à 18 ans
freshman ni contraints de vue et un ou
deux mauvais matchs hier pour effet
pourcentage baisse dans les boxes corsa
veut pas faire joli la réalité du match
les différentes souvent avec pat baldwin
c'est qu'on n'est pas d'accord c'est un
peu la même chose faut pondérer les
c'est normal que des mecs qui est de 18
ans il si elle est pâle et le stade que
des mails et donne deux ans et
mais les flashes ce qu'on a pu voir de
max christie que les plus jeunes pas le
doublé les mecs estampillé shooter de
cette offre c'est quand même de très
solides faut voir sur la l'intégrale
l'échantillon d'une saison voir ce qu'on
nous veut n'a vu avant et puis et puis
voilà mes cd les trois sont des profils
de bons shooteurs je pense mais colette
houston a peut-être un profil de faire
plus de choses que tu ajouté ouais il
est plus plus épais il écope enfin je
trouve qu'il est défensivement et pareil
pour impacter plus facilement plus et
fait moins agressif ouais alors que max
christie pour le coup il sort des écrans
j'ai vu la question jeux les jouets et
jeux d'eau pour toiser
bien ouais colonies ainsi
il épaulait voter mais en angleterre
on bouge ni jérémy sera de bages et rémy
sera niçois b lors du coup du côté des
preuves à côté de kendall bran prochain
sort du banc c'est un ailier mais je
crois qu'il a de 0,3 faut confirmer
latéralement moi j'aime bien je trouve
qu'il défend bien que kendall bois n'est
la plus d'aptitudes là dessus c'est un
joueur très collectif qui m'ont aucun
tir en développement par exemple prend
de plus en plus
en terme de dribble c'est pas un
créateur balle en main pour le moment
c'est plus un finisseur d'action même si
je trouve qu'il est capable de passer
correctement et comprendra le jeu gelé
enfin de loterie personnellement dans un
rôle à la télé ou bret dans un rôle à la
malle scotches genre de profil il joua
hulme l'an dernier les faits il avait
fait la une et gt2 ballon avec bon on en
avait parlé dans son article et ouais
c'est j'aime beaucoup le profil est pas
autant vu mais c'est intéressant
est-ce que ya d'autres questions on va
prendre les dernières questions
attendent que aussi à l'ex rédac on
gagne quand même l'europe par et et
astin comme ça
vous si vous avez des questions ou
surtout n'hésitez pas du coup tu ne fais
un petit topo sur tahiti où savidan
s'étalèrent alana
riley washington
est ce que est ce que c'est le nouveau
meneur de kentucky masqué par john
calipari qui aura un rôle différent nba
je ne sais pas je pense posant seulement
physique assez étrange tu avais dit
androgyne dans un dans un top case
préférant je trouve que c'est assez vrai
la dren joueurs au lycée dans l'arizona
et j'en fait cette année malheureusement
il est beaucoup trop souvent utilisés au
bol il est pas assez mis en on ne met
pas en avant je pense dans les choses
qui sait le mieux faire mais je trouve
qu'il est long défensivement c'est
intéressant trouve qui peut tirer peut
il ya une panoplie offensive plutôt
intéressante même s'il va pas non plus
extrêmement cercle même temps quand tu
joues avec oscar tchimou et et demond
greene c'est un peu bouché en termes
d'accès à la pointure mais je crois
beaucoup beaucoup en taille taille et
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup de joueurs
à la meilleure il sera mieux utiliser un
billet cotisations alors que moi j'y
crois moins que que alan style et je
l'utilisé la donne un fort message privé
je suis sa louange abuse un peu mais
s'il est en premier tour c'est parce
qu'ils jouent à kentucky chez moi parce
qu'il ya on sait qu'il ya un contexte
pourri et que ces joueurs là sont
baissées je trouve en fait c'est un des
joueurs encore une fois ou quand tu
regardes l'impression visuelle est très
différente des stats en fait c'est un
jour qui est très efficace près du
panier qui a un vrai dire et c'est donc
sur le terrain
était un peu frustré c'est pareil c'est
un joueur sur le terrain à l'impression
qu'il ait jamais balle en main et en
fait c'est le plus gros volume de dire
de l'équipe aussi qui crée beaucoup plus
que ce qu'on voit le problème c'est que
pour moi il est trop lent pour défendre
des extérieurs qui n'est pas assez pour
la passe pour être un créateur balle en
moins et qui parce qu'à demain et voilà
ne sais que c'est parce qu'ils
nécessaire forcément moi mais qui c'est
pas parce à une main ça les gêne j'avoue
et je ne trouve pas je trouve qu'ils
gèrent pas assez bien le contact pour
aller finir au panier et il utilise
beaucoup de flotteur est un joueur qui
peut pas d'un efficacement près du
cercle cette humanité oui je crois pas
quand même porteur de balle est donc
principal et comme il est petit je
l'achète pour coup - qui les vervins
pour moi
ça s'est bien passé un bon nouvel an
voilà qui vient de prendre non pas
à laval mais ok
lui mettre dans la tête c'est pour à sa
sortie sera très très bon choix je les
gardais encore 20 20 30 mais c'est juste
que j'y crois pas comme un top 10 comme
beaucoup qui veulent y voir un vrai
meneur le nouveau meneur de kentucky ça
se trouve ça se trouve mais j'ai trop de
fac pour le moment
la dernière question de raser le 4s
jackson davis appareil bi pour vous non
non non ne me salir est pas oui
je sais pas moi je suis je dirai pas le
nom de sicile et le rapt et en 35 qui va
faire du fonds un excellent finisseur
peut-être mais un finisseur
mais ça fait c'est le genre de profil
soit les détails leur coup clé
les badistes les mecs comme ça qui sont
des très bon finisseur mais il fait un
tout et quelques pilotes g league mais
j'y crois pas puisque ça
d'après la ajouté
oui après il est l'unique ogresse
lancers francs déjà ça y est tu es
toujours un bond de 70% malheureusement
messieurs on va s'arrêter là je vais
vous remercier merci à la halle merci
hugo
on va s'arrêter là je vais vous
souhaiter à tous bah déjà de passer de
continuer à passer des bonnes fêtes
faites attention à vous le variant tous
à l'alcool outil
on n'oublie pas de saluer bar on a une
pensée pour tous les gars a donc soit de
balle et les historiques manub n'ont pas
pu être là mais aussi tous là des latine
tous ceux qui travaillent dans l'ombre
big up aussi eu en toile donc on
n'oublie pas non plus que envergure
c'est un article par jour donc faut pas
hésiter à aller sur envergure poids co2
façon quotidienne vous commencez par
regarder les beaux scores de nba.com et
ensuite tout de suite après le bon
réflexe envergure principaux et vous
regardez l'article comme ça qu'ils
payent qu'il paru la veille je vous
souhaite à tous une bonne soirée on se
retrouve comme d'habitude dans un mois à
bientôt tout le monde salut salut